All right,
we're alive.
We're going in.
I'm here with Nick Depaulo.
Brian red band.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen.
And we're looking at the Cha,
the tunnel that they dug under,
I believe his name is El Chapo.
El Chapo Guzman.
Uh,
respect,
respect for everyone.
You know,
forget about all this terrible shit.
I'm sure that guy has done.
Listen,
you got to,
you got to give props when they're due.
This guy had,
I mean he's got a fucking plan.
He executed it like God Damn Clint Eastwood Movie.
This is a movie.
I'm a contract.
The work that the tunnel was perfect for Chrysler and he was in jail for a year.
So I wonder if it took a year for them to do this.
Oh Christ.
He's wondering how they did it.
Probably got a crew of six and they did it in three hours.
They talk to fucking mile tunnel.
Here's a video of him going into the hole to see if he could find the video
cause you actually see him go up.
See Ya.
He just fucking,
he just goes over to buy.
Whereas toilet is and just steps down into,
I'm not kidding,
man.
It's crazy.
That was a staircase.
It's like a movie and it's going to end with Trump.
You know,
all my God,
the baby's can be trumped.
Do you know his,
his um,
his son said something.
He texted something.
Jesus Christ.
How terrified must trumpy right now.
Do you imagine this fucking guy who can dig a tunnel a mile under the ground?
It comes up behind Trump Trump's house.
He's trying to kick your ass.
Isn't it weird that history is tweeted now?
Like it's in the past?
It used to be like by horse and messaged carrier.
Now it's strange.
So strange people on the run have,
you know,
well,
you've tested Twitter.
When you find out something happened,
like somebody died,
what do you do immediately?
I go to Twitter immediately.
I just go look in the timeline and that's for sure.
Something who it is.
Depends who it is.
A died my check my space on a couple of those guys.
Yeah,
like you would he would he see like rip?
Like,
like,
uh,
Leonard Nimoy was a big one for me.
I was like,
aw,
fuck's Bach.
Fucking Spock died and immediately went to Twitter and Bam.
It was right there.
I had a look at this.
He's got a motorcycle.
Sorry.
When we're watching this,
the hunt for El Chapo,
El Chapo was a fucking motorcycle and a juggle whiskey.
Like what does that jog on the front seat?
Can,
he's going to fucking party as soon as he gets on that thing.
I want to,
I want a motorbike and a gallon.
A cider.
This is like El Machete.
I mean it really is like he gets down through the hole.
There's a motorcycle with fine line rails on rails,
like a ride at fucking Disney and he's,
and he's gone look at that tunnel costs.
5 million took a year to build.
Holy Shit.
Boy.
The authorities are really fucking on top of it.
Huh?
How funny is that though?
That they take a wild guess at 5 million pitch?
You don't know how much we can get that price.
Just guessing what we call home depot and they said the,
uh,
the two by fours or late 60,
all the amount of 30 out of this place.
And I think you've got to factor in and union costs.
This is where,
this is his toilet.
So he,
what he did was they built it right behind the stall.
So I guess he has like a little bit of privacy there and that's where they
fucked up.
They gave him like a little bit of Shit or privacy.
Yeah.
Which,
which,
you know,
why would he do that?
Well now they know you can't give the Guy Shit or privacy.
If you catch them now you have to shit in the front of yourself.
I mean,
come on.
This is crazy.
This is like,
it's a colonoscopy.
Look Joe,
my butthole looks that good.
We're very happy.
It's that wide and clean.
It's ready to go licked out
this all protein powder stuck at assign fucking Elaine energy drinks and Joe
Coffee and all that.
They'll shakes and Moose.
That's my prostate and the wire hanging out on electronic prostate.
You see,
they're going to be able to make artificial penises.
They say within the next five years they're going to have lab created penises.
I'm already on the list.
He didn't like a year ago.
Can you imagine having the first generation of them?
Well,
I was at,
um,
I was in Miami the other day and I saw this woman that had an artificial,
but like the most obvious hot artificial butter or saying bad mouth.
It was so bizarre.
It was so strange.
But what happened was just went crazy.
You know,
she didn't say,
well,
and we'll get it and want to get a little butt lift out a little.
No,
she went nuts.
Here's El Chapo.
Watch this.
Watch them walk through this.
This is hilarious.
He's just hanging out.
Yeah.
You know,
just in my cell another day,
no big deal.
And then they give them like a knock,
knock,
knock.
He goes,
all right,
let's fucking do this.
And it goes back there.
Steps down.
Uber's here.
It's over.
How the fuck,
how the fuck do you know?
Respect that.
And for him,
5 million.
Like what a bargain.
You know,
it looked like he was doing that trick that people do when they walk behind a
wall that are potty.
They go like,
Hey,
do that when you're drunk.
The fake staring in the face tick.
That's exactly what it looked like.
That's hilarious.
And he's gone.
He's gone for now.
They had to be some cooperation and that was like too easy.
Now I know why you assume that you know you always think the worst of people and
I think that's one of your fault buddy,
which I'm like fucking strong points when you look at that and it's like,
I mean if that's about as clear an example of an inside job as you're ever going
to fucking fuck nobody hurt digging,
nobody heard nothing.
Nothing motorcycle starting up do you guys didn't notice that there's one lone
house that was just built a mile away.
He didn't know exactly where was the output?
Was it a house?
I thought I heard a dirt bike starting up in El Chapo.
No,
nothing.
My friend,
I smelled whiskey jug forum guy gas out there.
It gets a fucking jug of whiskey or whatever it was in that job.
Definitely.
It'd be Taylor.
I'm assuming it was booze made maybe a little,
a lot of fellows.
I mean it was a ton true.
Well,
he had a regular cell so they,
you know,
it wasn't like Goodfellas style.
Remember those guys just in the stacks coming in.
They're slicing the garlic with the razor blade.
You know who just knew how to make the sauce.
Yeah,
that fucking sauce.
I tried that after that.
I tried slicing the garlic with a route in.
I believe it's very annoying.
Yeah,
it's so not worth it.
My grandmother would even do that shit.
That's the kind of shit you do when you were in jail.
So He's no pussy.
You're,
you're lost and trapped in this horrible environment where people tell you what
to do every day.
I just decided to find out new ways to chop garlic,
but they,
some people did live like that,
right?
Like that's real shit.
Like really did have like cordoned off areas in jails.
How the fuck did they ever pull that off?
Same Way El Chapo.
But that's even kind of crazier cause at least El Chapo,
you could kind of say you didn't know until the end if there's a whole section
of your jail carpets over the fucking bar so he can't see in and you smell
cooking and the guards getting mad because they don't have fans.
So they're frying steaks in there.
Yes.
Smokes cat and everywhere.
Those two guys that brought,
brought up upstate New York,
in that prison,
you were allowed to put sheets up to block the view of the,
we can put sheets in front of you.
So yes,
that was allowed.
So it became like a really shitty apartment.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
I mean,
how was that allowed in a prison that doesn't seem like prison ish and hillbilly
bill.
I mean,
what the fuck that's gotta be?
One of the weirdest things about being a prison is that you don't,
no one sees you see everybody like no one.
And was any privacy feel like constantly exposed to it.
That's very unnatural.
Just that alone.
I mean you got to,
but obviously you see something like this where all he had was like a little,
little tiny wall over the shitter,
like next to the shitter.
I don't even like shitting at Fenway,
you know?
I can't imagine being in a cell than other guy three feet away.
There's those decisions you have to make though,
right?
Like Airport Shit,
you've got to go,
we're just going to do this regardless of how disgusting it smells in there and
what what was in the toilet already.
Sometimes you just got to get rid of a package.
Those are the worst.
The airport,
especially international terminal,
she got 11 different odors coming out of live in different stuff you could carry
next fucking coffee from Colombia food court.
I was in Miami the other day and I had to go through immigration and when I was
going through the immigration thing,
there's this giant fucking line of people and everywhere you looked as he Ebola
signs does he signs like if you have an elevated temperature,
don't do this,
don't do that.
And they have all these,
there's like four or five Ebola signs right in front of me.
Warning.
Have you been to Liberia?
Have you been to?
We went,
we were in Costa Rica.
It's Liebherr.
[inaudible] but it's spelled Liberia.
You know,
my wife is like,
are we going to get Ebola?
Like is very bold on this fucking no,
it's Africa like us.
The need for borders,
Joe.
But what about those poor people that have Ebola?
What do we over fuck everybody in the world of fucking,
I just don't think that we deserve it.
I know you don't even know.
I'm Rose's country.
How dare you
hate this?
America,
can I.
Dot.
I love this country.
I just think that other people are,
they are fucked.
We
need to help him there.
There we are.
We're in trouble.
There's not enough.
There's no way we'd be paying way more if we were actually helping Africa.
Now.
That's true.
I just need what we're rebuilding.
You know,
if like if we rebuild Iraq,
imagine if we just decided to do that.
Just start rebuilding infrastructures of cities just without war.
It's going there.
Big Time.
Government contracts just rebuild like Liberia,
Liberia,
if you've never seen it,
there's a vice documentary on it and have a summer home over there inside or
outside the shit way cause it's like an area where people just shit on the
street.
You've got to make sure you want to make sure you're not downwind of that.
Real estate prices are very north east,
south of the property value.
It's,
well uh,
Shane Smith from vice went down there years ago and they did this,
um,
this documentary on how crazy Liberia was.
You'll love this.
One of the things that happened in Liberia is I believe it was a place where
they put a lot of slaves once they were set free once,
like American slaves and went back to Africa.
I think that was also a big part of Liberia and the,
the,
the government collapsed there.
I give you,
if you're really interested in the story,
don't listen to it for me cause I'm going to butcher it.
But Shane's a vice piece kind of details where that country went wrong and you
know,
it's,
it's fucking chaos there now.
Like they had their server like eat these little carts where they serve food on
the side of the road.
They were serving human meat and you don't have this guy recognized,
get that.
And Los Anica
recognizes it because he had her eating human meat,
so he knew what it tasted like,
so he turned the guy in.
It is what part of that story was I suppose to love.
You Go,
you'll love them that you're going to end slavery.
You loved all of that.
I thought you'd be in this.
You'll go,
you'll love this,
and you went right into the slavery part.
Like I'm pro slavery.
That's not what I'm saying.
You love this because it's fascinating.
Oh,
you love.
It's because it's fascinating.
Not because you love it.
I didn't say specific.
I love it.
You were saying everybody does that to me.
You have one too many appearances on Fox News.
They just like Nicholas.
You're our go to guy.
They won't even have me on anymore.
Really?
They're like just to racist.
No,
fucking racist.
I'm kidding.
I don't think you want to just say that.
I win the argument,
Joe.
It's true how it works.
That is true.
I know it is true,
right?
That's one of the for your racist or sexist or misogynist,
like,
oh shit.
By the way,
all words that were made up,
they're not even part of the fucking Latin.
They were made up for the causes.
I don't know if you know that,
but uh,
I'm a fan of America and we don't go by Latin language.
We have American English.
We're done with that Latin shit.
We add onto it as we like CIS gender.
You've got to start adopting that.
Don't even understand what that means.
CISGENDER.
Do you know what that means?
That means if you are heterosexual and you are the gender of your birth,
so if you are a heterosexual white man,
you are a cis gendered white man.
What does that mean exactly?
Let's just adopt it.
Let's get something straight.
Flat.
It's exactly,
exactly.
And gender is not a social construct and we get that right.
How dare you?
Some girls second by social construct last night.
Oh,
you fucking lesbian pipe.
I look at the sauce.
I'll fucking outrageous a statement by Nick Depalo.
Um,
genders.
Definitely not a social construct.
It's a,
there's males and females,
but there's also a spectrum inside that male and female and there's women who
are men or men or women and they absolutely think that's absolutely right.
I don't think it does.
You can deny it at a certain point in time.
Right now that's just biology.
But I'll say CIS gender just cause it's fun just because I feel silly saying it.
It's got the word [inaudible] in.
It almost seems like a pro lesbian thing.
Yeah.
Sis Gender.
Umbro gender,
Bro.
Gendered.
That's,
that's a guy who wants things the old fashioned way.
Now.
All of that to reactionary.
Yeah.
Reactionary.
I used to think as someone who reacts to things quickly,
everybody did,
and then it's a right wing.
It's reacting to things in a right wing slant because somebody said that about
my act,
about me being a reactionary,
like what do they mean?
Does he mean I jumped down the throats?
A heckler?
Yeah.
Well it sounds like that's what it should mean,
right?
It's what everybody thinks it initially.
That's one of those weird words like how do you make up a new word?
Why do you have the same word is reaction,
reaction,
you know best saying.
I mean like you already have reaction.
We all know what that means and everybody knows what Arie means.
You add it,
you're doing it right.
You're reactionary.
What are you doing?
Why are you making a new definition yet?
Fuck.
Am I looking at you like Brian made a dictionary,
Webster over there.
Why?
I tried to say 1000th 1000th that is not easy and I can't do it in 1000 thousand
yeah,
I had to think about that.
Can you do that?
Well,
1000th 1000th,
that's not easy.
I just fucked it up.
But you had a concentrate.
Yeah.
And that weird.
Yeah,
it's a weird one.
But if you had a hair lip,
it's a real pitch.
I was like freaking out for top guy.
Is Jack Jockeying Phoenix?
Is he like the most successful here?
Lift guy ever or is it the guy who was Stacy Keach?
Which guy has that ever been asked?
It's the best question.
I'm looking.
It's a good to question.
She had a hair lip said Ryan.
He just doesn't believe he didn't believe he did or am I confusing?
I always computers.
What was that show he was on?
He's been on a lot of stuff.
That detective show.
I'll wait a minute.
I think Kate,
she's alive.
I'm confusing him with a guy that Jamie,
you'll find out.
Is he alive?
All right.
Stacy,
how does the ONA introductions for opiod?
Anthony didn't know that.
Yes.
Is that right?
See if you could find Stacy Keach reading opie and Anthony introduction cause
it's fucking awesome.
I always confuse him with a guy that was in,
you know what with Dinero and Charles Grodin.
Uh,
you know the Oh road movie flushes man.
Midnight run.
What's the guy's name?
But he reminds me,
Stacy Keach,
the handsome guy who just died.
He's dead by the way,
with a mustache to played the bad guy.
Serrano.
What the fuck?
This is what happens and I sleep two hours a night.
I'm like member's name Eric.
Nope.
Make some motions over there.
I was going to go to you is one of my backup guy.
There's a few of those guys like that.
Like Stacy Keach was always in those.
Charles Grodin.
No,
not groans.
And your guy that played the bad guy.
He's been in every gap for Dennis freelance dentist.
He just died a while ago.
Died.
He died,
which shocked me.
He looked like a healthy,
like handsome guy who was going to live.
Well,
there's still did.
How was it being sarcastic?
He did look yellow.
It was very vibrant.
He was a Chicago cop in real life.
Well that's
probably the stress you probably right to be drank like a fish.
Right?
Well,
I was talking to this lady yesterday,
Doctor Rhonda Patrick.
He's brilliant doctor,
and she was talking about the effects of aging on the effects of partying,
drinking,
and he then just bad health and how much it can age your body,
age,
literally your biological body.
I don't know why I'm looking at Dennis Farina
with Dennis Furry.
It's good stuff.
But Dennis Farina freak out in here.
No,
you'd be all right.
You sure we're friends.
All bleed together.
I'll hold your hand,
but uh,
Dennis Farina,
by going through all those years as a cop,
you've got to think the fucking stress of that.
You,
you,
you pay for that.
You pay with that for a long time.
But that's one of the reasons why he was so believable.
I can sense right.
How good was that's right.
And snatched it.
Yeah.
You believe,
even though he was sort of tongue and cheek while he was doing it,
he was still on board.
That he observed that he was that fucking guy.
You know,
he was a good actor,
man.
Yeah.
He was bombing to shout.
That was a bummer.
But listen to this Stacy Keach thing.
This is the Stacy Keach,
opie and Anthony.
Thank you.
York City
out of control.
Satellite Radio show is being broadcast to millions of Americans.
Here we go.
Here's the bed at the controls reg.
I would love to say we have the best job in America and did it Kumiai and
alcoholic be the best thing ever.
And the gym North out loud laugh.
How do we explain the show?
We should start,
oh,
here
is the treatment.
And make up the opie and Anthony show a popular radio program known for the
cream style of entertainment.
Very few limits.
Oh Shit.
This is a freak show out.
Anyway.
Anybody want to come on his self as it guests under the right circumstances?
Something weird going to happen.
I don't give a fuck.
Laugh out loud,
which I love.
That's what I love.
In the past they have been accused of multiple FCC violations and they've even
got from their show suspended from satellite radio and listen to our show you
what you get.
You know what we are every day and to conquer,
fall down the jokes.
All eight of on Cock and ball.
You're awake.
Die
Real people.
Really excited.
Get ready to experience the thrill of a lifetime.
Use
The opie and Anthony show.
So powerful.
The hell do we.
That's about,
that's about as good an intro as any radio guys ever gotten except Stacy Keach
region afro like Joe Rogan started his podcast five years ago.
Well,
I started a podcast because of opiate.
Anthony is that Brian and I,
we had done some other shit before.
We'd done like Justin TV and um,
we had done like these little things where you,
you know,
you do like a little a live read off the laptop camera and talk to people and
you check Twitter questions and shit.
We fucked around with that a few times.
But when Anthony set up his green screen in his basement and started doing that
live from the compound show,
it was like,
Whoa,
Tom Green,
sane.
He had servers in his house like those fucking long giant fucking sewer cables
running through his living room.
All we had the whole deal.
He had a whole server room.
You would go in the room.
They,
it was everything like those,
those homes out Jesus' hands and shit.
You're like,
whoa.
I talked to him Monday,
add him on this show and uh,
he meets at this doughnut place now.
He has a studio now in Burbank.
He moved it out of his house and he meets at this doughnut place,
next store.
And I for his studio audience as he's like,
he'll periscope and go,
anyone who comes into his doughnut place,
you can be a part of my studio audience.
And then they all go over to his studio and they did the show in front of wow.
Just complete strangers.
He meets at a doughnut place.
That's perfect for him.
Yeah.
He was a super pioneer.
Tom Green's show that fucking original MTA show.
Very,
very underrated show.
He's a pioneer.
He's a funny,
a good dude man.
Very,
very good dude.
Yeah,
he's a good dude.
We need more of them down here.
I think.
I did think he was on that fucking celebrity pool show that I did
too.
And that girlfriend,
that TV.
That's hilarious.
Yeah,
he's just,
yeah,
he was on that and I'm pretty sure piece of,
he's always been like a really cool dude,
you know,
just so interesting.
Weird guy.
And you know what,
it didn't start doing standup until later in life and got really good.
Like he had a showtime special and I was sitting in front of the TV and I think
he'd only been doing standup like four or five years and it was funny.
It was funny.
It was well written,
it was well put together.
He had really good points.
Has been about texting,
what people's thumbs are going to look like and what they're,
how they're going to change.
It was fucking hilarious.
It was really good.
It was like well acted out.
I was like,
this guy looks like a 10 year comic,
but it's just because he had done so many other things and he's like really used
to comfortable in front of Peter.
Tom Green's bad motherfucker.
He killed it Monday man.
He had the crowd going crazy.
He did a 20 minutes sat to
on the show.
I'm sure he's an animal.
He's good and he's working hard too.
That's another thing about that guy.
He's always doing something.
He's always working,
you know,
he doesn't,
it doesn't rest.
It's always trying to improve things.
So like him,
like that definitely influenced us.
But opie and Anthony did about the,
by the way,
they held their show like they were,
the only show that I ever went on was a hang that's,
you know,
I brought guys in and I'm like,
Hey,
this is my friend Eddie,
this is my friend Brian is my friend Joey.
This is my friend Ari.
I brought guys in and they were like,
you know,
who's this guy bring them in,
and they're just so cool like that there.
So they were,
what they did was they turned it into like a fun place to hang out.
So everybody got funny air because of that.
Like it was way like Patrice,
this kind of Shit Patrice to at ONA,
you literally could not have done that on any other radio format because people
had no Patrice give him the room,
like let them get these rants out.
You had to know like when the rants or come,
we gotta help them along and you've got to not like want to be the center of
attention.
Like they had the best,
the best control of the room because like opie would just lay back.
He would just late like literally you'd see him push back and let Norton and
Patrice and you,
you guys would all be fucking yelling at each other.
It'd be hilarious.
Well it's smart actually.
I mean when you've been doing radio that long,
trust me,
there's nothing better than having good guests with it.
You can sit back and let him go cause you're tired of carrying this shit.
But think about how few shows wherever like that's right.
Right.
No,
it's a great wrestle few shows.
When you did that show with rd,
did they have like a format they had you guys stick to the radio show?
Well yeah because that was a unique situation because it uh,
we were all on TV.
Simulcasts a direct TV.
It had to be,
it had to be more structure,
which was to me was the problem,
you know,
and already two already want it to less structure to the men at the dumb idiot
TV gun vault,
which is with a lot of ticket paid what we did and stuff.
But you know,
it takes kind of the fucking,
the craziness.
You can get away with a lot of shit on radio and you can get a lot of what it
will wait with a lot of shit on radio and you can get a lot of away with a lot
of shit on the Internet.
And when you look at like something that's on direct TV like that,
I'm like,
boy,
this isn't there a better way to advertise.
Can you guys have just like a ticker at the bottom?
Like wouldn't that be a better way to advertise?
It just seems like breaking it up and doing every 15 minutes to do like however
long it is,
like seven minutes or eight minutes off the air where it's just bullshit and
commercials,
then you come back,
it breaks up the whole flow,
like conversations,
like the best conversations like this conversation,
like we're having fun.
So a ganache and it keeps going.
Yeah,
we're banging.
Or if we go,
all right,
we'll be right back.
Uh,
we have a word from and then we'd have to start all over again.
It is its momentum and rhythm.
You're right.
It's like the difference between driving on the highway and taken side roads.
Like if you took side roads and there's an open highway next to you,
you're an asshole.
Like when you doing,
you know,
but some people they take the
side roads driving motherfuckers.
I'll tell you that,
that,
that weighs app to have that on your fonts.
Amazing.
Cause I,
you know,
I lived out at 15 years ago.
I don't remember the,
to the fucker.
I've
been relying on this thing all week.
It's been taking me around traffic and I'm supposed to be on the one on one had
kicked me off and I'm looking at people sitting and traffic and like you said,
up over hills and shit.
But I'm still moving to them.
I'd rather move and be late,
but you don't even late.
It gets you there faster.
I mean,
it's fucking unbelievable.
Amazing to hear what they're doing though.
Some people in neighborhoods are pissed off because that sometimes ways will
direct it to their neighborhoods.
So now these people in neighborhoods are putting fake like reports.
Uh,
yeah.
Once again,
selfish and disrupt.
Damn selfish motherfuckers.
Nick Depaulo little traffic in the fucking bell area.
Get the,
yeah.
Well do you remember when cops two cops are pissed because it lets people know
what the cops I've seen is,
you know,
seems to be open season on the cops are,
that's a legitimate point.
Cops are faking it.
They're like putting fake cop like warnings up in spots.
So that would the DELAC looking around everywhere.
Good fighting back now is that when we
come back with deception,
I don't think that should be legal because a,
it's our tax dollars.
I don't,
I don't want to pay tax dollars.
Somebody is fucking lying to me.
That's bullshit.
You're lying to ways dare you.
It's like I'm the shit that's going on.
What was this other case?
Um,
oh Pida and seaworld that uh,
a seaworld guide infiltrated Peta and was working from the inside at Peta to try
to destroy Peta but can saying a bunch of ridiculous shit.
And he was an employee of seaworld.
Is that right?
Oh Man.
I'm out.
Be a good document.
Let me make sure I'm getting that right because it's,
it might be the other way around.
See world either way it would make for a great movie.
Right.
That'd be like a good Jim Carrey movie.
Yeah.
Are you guys ready for divorce fest this year?
Uh,
once they,
Ashley Madison,
uh,
passwords get put into a searchable database online and it's going to,
it's going to cause a way,
but shit that's going on.
It's going to be crazy.
We finally get all who finally let met gay people marry each other.
Got That right?
Yeah.
Now regular Mary just talks.
Like looking at all my friend's wife's going,
Huh?
Why stick to whack?
And it,
it's good.
We'll move.
It's a good move.
It's way safer.
Peter says undercovers seaworld employee animal rights activists.
So I did have it right.
That's hilarious.
Really overzealous seaworld employee,
like Paul Blart Mall cop style.
He'll be a great movie.
You can't just call somebody.
You know,
I,
if I was in the movie world,
I would call somebody,
but Melissa McCarthy will be the whale.
Oh,
how dare you.
And she's a funny woman around.
Uh,
she's very funny.
She's very physically funny for sure.
She's a very talented,
yeah.
It's funny cause Billy Gardell is a funny comic.
You know Billy,
right?
Yeah.
They don't like on the show.
He's like almost like a straight guy.
Of course wouldn't want the husband getting one over on the wife.
What'd you Joe?
They don't allow that.
Nick does not.
Why is that?
What's so what's up with that fuck has jerk offs run Hollywood.
Is that it?
Is that what people want to see?
Do people want to see that?
I don't want to see that you don't walk in.
Holly has been hijacked by fucking feminists.
Wow.
I really think am I wrong then if you guys can't relate that and I'm fucking
leaving I think.
Do you ever notice the pattern of emasculation and movies and it fucked the last
20 years?
I think there's people that are seriously concerned with coming off as
progressive and even if they think differently than what would be the
progressive choice,
they will make the progressive choice cause they get like social brownie points.
I definitely think that's true,
but I don't think that pertains to sitcoms.
I think like it's not as funny if the dude gets over on the CIC for someone to
come on.
This is a true story.
One hairstyle,
I might have told you this on the last time I was here,
they had a deal with a,
this was years ago,
Dennis Larry's company.
When we come out here and take a bunch of meetings and forget for like,
you know,
they had a sitcom idea and at first of all,
every meeting,
75% of the room was female executives.
And of course the first question in every meeting was what's the wife's role?
Every fucking one.
So by the time we got to NBC,
which was the last one,
and I had fucking had it,
and they're like,
so what's the wife?
I go and again,
I was just kidding.
But I go,
oh,
I don't know.
I see.
Like in the pilot,
she's pregnant and I pushed her down the cellar stairs
and I'm expecting like Dennis to start laughing and in Serpico Jimmy Syrup and
they all just look at me.
You could have fucking her and a pen.
So the next day,
next day,
Jimmy SerpBook had to send a dozen roses to the lady from MPs.
Oh my God,
I can't get a Gig.
Thank God you throw me a news radio and a few breaks on the fires and I'd still
be using my fucking,
you know,
my high school acting.
You almost got fucked over the news radio gig.
We had to go back and get,
yeah,
that was hilarious,
man.
There was some shenanigans behind the scenes.
Somebody who was trying to get their friend in on the part that nick was
playing.
And I had cast nick as my one brother and Callan is my other brother.
I'm like,
if you want it to be funny,
how about I bring you two really funny standups than I'm actually friends with.
Like let's just do it this way.
And so Paul Simms was like,
yeah,
fuck it.
Perfect.
Like you saw,
you had seen some stand up,
you'll you guys hilarious.
Perfect man.
And so,
uh,
you,
you came in and all of a sudden,
you know,
nick calls me up.
He goes,
Hey,
I guess I didn't get the fucking job.
I don't know what happened and what what and that we had to go back down there
and they had cast somebody else and we made them switch it around you.
I didn't even get home and call you.
You.
You came running out.
Remember I was walking to my,
all right,
that's right.
I was walking to my car,
got one.
Then there's another one down the fucking toilet.
I'll be back in Boston and another six weeks of this keeps up and Joe comes
running out of nowhere and goes,
they fucked up to,
and then I'm going,
now I'm saying,
thinking of myself is Joe just been a great guy.
I don't want to fuck over a guy who actually was better than me in the audition.
No,
I know you.
no,
no.
It wasn't that at all.
You was already decided.
Somebody I didn't know that somebody snuck in.
It was the decision was made by Paul who was the producer.
He
thought you were hilarious and he loved the idea.
Since we're already friends,
I guess it'd be perfect.
Don't know each other and we look like we could be brothers.
We have this antagonistic relationship on the show with know and I beat the fuck
out of each other.
He throws me through a glass window was like,
student is fun.
I got some through like one of those candy glasses.
You don't even feel it man.
It's just like does it dissolves you go flying,
you hit it and it just dissolves.
It's real weird.
Like you're waiting to get cut open.
You know you went into like,
oh this is going to be ugly.
And just,
yeah,
that was fun.
And we had another scene,
where are we supposed to,
I don't put a beaten you up or one of the brothers,
but we were hitting you with a glass coffee pot over the head and we started
stopping on Ya.
And they watched him through the thing and they go,
hey,
it looks like Goodfellas.
Looks like killing somebody
to Italian for this.
I had a suit jacket off.
Don't miss like Deniro and stomping on
the glass.
Fake Glass Coffee Pot.
That was awesome.
That sugar glass.
Yeah,
that was fun.
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
No,
it's funny how your memory fucks with you Joe.
no,
no.
20 years.
Those 20 years ago.
Really?
I don't want to hear that.
Isn't that crazy?
I think it was nine to five.
You're right.
I,
I moved out now.
I was out in La in 1995 to 99 so it was one of those years and uh,
that's what I can't believe I'm driving around out here.
I'm looking at people who were my age when I came off.
Yeah,
the cycle.
You guys used to look at me out here.
They don't even look at me now.
Gay Guys.
I got a friend that we could work on a few days and we can get it back.
We'd get it back.
You're not,
you're a handsome guy.
P 90 exit again.
Last time you were here you were telling me about you did the p nine dx.
He lost a ton of weight.
I get fit.
I did that.
You know,
he's supposed to do it for three months.
I did it for like 13 months in turn my hips into fucking fine powder.
So now I'm doing Shaunti undoing Shaunti.
What does she mean it and sanity you to stay with it.
You've got your [inaudible].
What's better?
P90X or that?
Well,
this is all body weight.
Is that what it is?
Yeah,
there's no way.
You know what Joe,
it's pretty close.
I,
I did this insanity if the thing had this little,
but you know what?
I fucking like it.
Here's the funny thing.
Joe Is the hilarious thing.
I'm doing this and everybody,
I figured everybody in the video is in their twenties and you know,
at old 30th,
the oldest and a,
so I'm doing a lot of the modified exercises.
You know,
they always have the fat chick on the front.
It's doing modified.
Everybody else is doing like one hit,
one out,
pushups and me and Catherine and going like this,
this will get me in shape by 2046 like I,
but you know what?
It gets your heart rate through the roof.
I mean,
and,
and uh,
I just do it to maintain now,
you know what I mean?
But at work,
I mean it's a,
you can get really good workouts from bodyweight exercises.
Yes.
This is a bunch of them that you can do.
There's like a bunch of a full body weight routines that you could do that are
fucking incredible.
They'll kill you.
They break you down.
Yeah.
These have the,
you know,
you're doing those burpee pushups and suicides and 30 minutes so that you know,
and you get a break every five minutes.
You got
like a ten second break and it keeps my,
you know,
it allows me to have cigarettes after I work on,
you could do that on the Xbox with the camera that records you.
So it tells you,
it knows if you're not doing the arm high enough and point much like you're
white,
your person.
I look at my belly if want to see if that'll tell me I'm not doing it right.
I've always said that that was,
there would be a really good way to teach martial arts.
They have that.
Do they have it?
They have,
they have all that stuff now and it uses the body like body tracking and it can
tell like how,
how much calories you've burned.
And it's,
it's really cool that I would like to teach you because if,
um,
if you did an instructional and you're showing a guy like how to throw a kick,
if you put it on a computer where the lines of the guy's legs were clearly
defined,
you would know if he's like knee wasn't high enough or if his hands were down or
for his back.
What is this?
It right here.
You have c has quick workout with Greg Jackson.
Oh.
And so the one on the right is the guy,
the little thing and the triangles
video of you and see,
wow,
that's crazy.
And it's like what?
Infrared or something like that.
So I could tell where your hot spots are and read your heart rate to Oh my God.
By looking at Xbox one,
what heart rate by looking at you?
It's thermal camera and we can't beat Isis really fucking shitting me.
Okay.
It's because we don't want to be nice as we want to keep an enemy out of
whatever.
Maybe.
Do you think that,
no,
I hear it's frank
UFC personal trainer hitting the Mitts with Frank Mir.
Oh Wow.
Look at this.
You throw your punches at his hands.
How many people are going to punch her fucking TV?
This is a terrible idea.
No,
anything that's standing close to your TV or TV since this came out.
I'll people do stand closer TV.
Matt Bacak whack,
whack,
whack.
So it's a good idea.
I think the way it would be better though is if it was a split screen and the
uh,
the character was begging your characters and much,
much larger because you need right now it's a little green guy that was in the
Flintstones sitting on your shelf.
Kazoo,
Kazoo.
That's what I'll looks like.
That's exactly what it looks like.
Cause you remember Kazoo?
That's Kazoo.
I know you can find what's a second,
cause I remember,
I feel like,
I know
I'm,
I'm not sure.
No,
that's not it.
Um,
that's kind of like maybe like less k.
Yeah.
K actually who did the voice,
Harvey Harvey Coleman from the Carol Burnett show.
Wow.
Funny motherfucker.
That was a great fucking show.
He's been gone a while to think about that man.
Someone like the Calbert Carol Burnett show.
That was a show back when there was only like three hits rise.
How Paul exactly.
And they were good.
They were very good.
The honeymooners is a good fucking shot him for like that kind of a sitcom.
It is a good fucking show.
My wife's,
she dvrs the Carol Burnett show now.
I watched a couple of the laugh my balls.
Good man.
I mean the writing,
is it funny and smart and what's up?
You want to hear his voice?
Yeah.
Wait,
that's,
yeah,
maybe what's going on there?
Look into it first.
That's a song.
The the song.
Um,
oh,
uh,
Lucille ball.
That's another fun.
I Love Lucy was a great fun show.
I liked her,
the dialog between her and her husband,
but when I got into this silly shit with her,
fallen into chocolate and shit,
I dunno.
She lost me a little bit.
They're well written show and he came up with it.
The camera,
the three camera shoot thing.
That was back when it was okay for a white chick to bank a Cuban guy too.
Yeah,
they can't do it.
And beat up by,
well before was like sophisticated.
Like in the 50s and the 60s the hotels,
we would go down there on plantation.
It was very mobbed up,
you know,
they'd go down there and gamble.
It was a wild place.
So a guy from Cuba was like a romantic guy.
Like a guy was a fucking musician from Cuba was like,
Whoa,
this guy's like exciting.
He's exotic.
You know.
It was like a good thing for her to be doing this guy with his funky accent.
Whereas from then on,
from,
from the embargo on,
it became,
you know,
this enemy that lived off our shores and the Castro years and all that crazy
shit and the bay of pigs and the fucking Russian missiles where they're putting
missiles in Cuba facing America Macaque.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah.
And that was all those post I love Lucy,
which is pretty fucking fascinating.
I blame it on her now.
Like now that you mention it,
now you feel like in red here they put it together.
That Fred Mertz,
I'll tell you,
he was a real antique Cuban guy.
I saw Carol Burnett last year.
I saw her in a restaurant.
Did you really get in there Carol Burnett's hanging in there as you look good
man.
Don't live.
Yeah.
She looked very healthy,
very healthy,
very vibrant.
Talking to the waitress and I was on a talk show.
She did.
She looked,
she's gotta be over 80.
She gotta be way over.
And how about Betty White?
She said,
you know,
she's 82 and I just saw Betty White jogging by this building like 10 minutes for
real.
No.
Yeah.
That's how you know when things are bad for you.
Do 80 year old ladies do it.
Yeah,
then don't do it.
I used to make fun of these workouts,
people jumping around in the living room and fuck these people were like,
they're going to get in shape.
I do this how I live for it.
You love those things.
They do.
They,
uh,
my problem and you know this Joe,
when you get your heart rate up,
it's the next two days I'm starving,
right?
I can't stop and I have no willpower.
And my wife,
she's one of these people that,
you know,
fucking eats anything,
doesn't gain weight.
I can't,
I can't go to bed until I eat.
Like,
you know,
three cylinders.
I can't help my,
so what do you do this?
We'd killed it.
No worries at all.
No coke.
Do I have to go back to doing coke?
Then I wouldn't have to exercise if I did that.
Yep.
I think it's just,
you got to give yourself moderation.
Give yourself one night a week where you really go off and you allowed to have
sandwiches.
You allowed to fucking stay up and eat cookies and milk.
I swear I do.
I have like a night a week where I just eat like a fucking slob in front of the
TV.
But that's like going,
you know,
that's like go and get a nice blow job and then fucking no blow jobs for another
six days.
But you,
so you need it again.
You need those cookies.
I don't eat cookies and shit.
I don't like,
but what do you eat?
What's your thing?
I don't know.
No,
I don't even lie.
I'm not even like a junk food guy,
but my wife is.
I opened the thing and there's a fucking eight pound bag of smart Cheddar
popcorn.
I love cooking for myself late at night when everyone's asleep,
cook all the time.
Sometimes I'll just cook a full meal for myself late at night,
late at night,
two o'clock in the morning.
I'll make vegetables.
I'll make some pasta.
Why not?
What is,
you're a fucking,
I'm a grown ass man.
You're going to work out the next kettlebells.
God dammit.
No,
you're right.
Life's too short.
Yeah.
Why not know I'm a fucking comic.
If I want to be up at two o'clock in the morning,
I mean that's,
I never went to bed before four o'clock in the morning until I was almost 30
years old.
I guess work even now though,
do you make proper meals or do you make inventions and like sometimes it's
bullshit.
You know,
sometimes I'll,
I'll do a blue apron.
I'll do one of those blue apron meals.
You ever seen that one of my sponsors.
I'm not trying to work in a spa.
I know we're going to like that.
Great.
They give you this,
um,
detailed to directions for how to cook something with photographs and all the
right portions,
all the right food and the right portions and you just cook it.
You just follow it,
your kids idiot proof and it's great.
Like you don't have to measure anything.
He just said,
oh,
next step opened that packet,
throw that in there and mix that up and then put the fish on the grill,
you know?
See and it's,
yeah,
see a great show.
You're making a nice fish in the grill at two in the morning.
I'm making a six pound bird,
Joel stuffed with Mozzarella cheese and Salami.
And my favorite thing is grilling meat in my underwear late at night.
Fuck underwear.
I just
discard the shit.
Yeah,
the hot splatters.
I want to protect my balls and shaft,
the very least.
Everything else.
Like I'll do a little hot grease splatter on my stomach.
It looks sexy.
Memorial war wounds.
Do you still do the kettle bells?
Yeah,
I still do that.
Thank you.
There's a great video.
I do call the extreme kettlebell cardio workout.
It's this one little kettle bell.
You could do it like a 35 pounder or if you want to get crazy,
you go to 45 pounds.
So it's not a heavy weight,
but swinging at p Diddy's kit you?
No,
he swung it.
The coach almost perfect.
I was in such a rush to get it out of.
Damn.
Coffee's delicious.
I'm going to have to fucking take a hit of that joint slumming it.
They might not say it out.
Is that right?
So what did he did he not,
he didn't make contact.
He swung it.
Yeah,
just being as level head itself,
you know?
Um,
you know,
how's that work?
That's all good.
I got off.
He,
you know,
he didn't drop.
Yeah,
they dropped the chairman.
They didn't want to press charges for him,
which probably means a big,
huge thing of cash.
Fucking yeah.
Tech coaches have had a bit of a history himself.
Like,
he's the guy who at trip,
the guy on the sideline when he was coaching for the jets.
Oh,
read against the Miami Dolphins.
The guy was returning a covering a punt and you know,
he ran out of bond in this coach sticks is put out.
They got 'em on slow motion trip and the guy that's hilarious.
Like a guy for that.
I'm a why that sounds like a real fun guy.
Coach.
Sounds like it'd be really hard not to beat that guy's ass.
It's like sal,
I in news or something.
You know.
So a time that I'm from Long Island,
but uh,
I don't know almost,
I know almost nothing about sports unfortunately already came on,
do the podcast.
He was so upset with me.
He was like,
I told him I was,
I turned Vegan and you know,
started [inaudible].
No,
no,
but I mean it was like that.
He was like,
what really?
You don't fall for anything?
I was like,
no,
I don't follow any of,
they're not baseball.
Like,
he's like,
he was incredulous.
He's like,
there's no way you got enough going on.
Oh yeah,
I'm at some fucking hottest sport going.
Well,
I watched professional pool.
It's not like I'm not into stupid shit.
I just don't have enough time for any other,
did you play him and Paul because he can show you please.
Good.
I know he played good.
Yeah,
we a little people like in Newark when he was 12.
And that's what he said.
I believe him.
He plays good art.
He's a fun dude,
man.
Absolutely funny fucking dude.
He was a perfect example of a,
a great joke that,
you know,
people didn't just cry too soon.
They said,
you can't even say this.
And this was when,
um,
he already said that he was banging his black chick and he goes in the middle of
it,
she goes,
I can't breathe.
He goes,
hey honey,
let's not make this political
right after Eric car twice.
I mean,
it was fucking hilarious.
And so many people were mad at him.
I could not stop laughing when I heard it.
I could not stop laughing just because,
not because I,
you know,
think it's funny that the guy got choked at that amount was going against that.
But that is a God damn funny.
It's funny.
And if you can't,
you can't see the funny in that.
It's either because you're friends with Eric Gardner or you're an asshole.
All right.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's it.
You don't think that's funny.
Come on.
That's fucking funny and hilarious.
Absolutely.
That's already,
he's a fucking character,
man.
I mean,
I just,
I'm Jo,
have you have you have a plan?
Don't this club tonight.
Ventura Harbor Comedy Club.
Really good doing that next month.
All right.
That's really good.
I think counting,
I haven't done it.
Callen just did it though.
You said it was amazing.
It was Callen yeah.
I'm pretty sure it's calendar or Dunkin Glue.
Fuck did it.
I Dunno.
I think it was Callen.
Yeah.
But I've heard great things.
There next month that Harry is very ignored like Ventura and into Santa Barbara.
Santa Barbara's very,
that's what,
that's what worries me.
It's great spot.
No,
it's no,
I mean ignored by comics.
Yeah.
Fucking Santa Barbara is one of the best places,
you know?
And if you go,
they don't,
not that far up.
Thank God.
No,
Santa Barbara is an hour from here,
but this hasn't been sure.
This isn't been Ventura.
Ventura is close.
It's 45 minutes.
Yeah,
45 minutes.
That's good spot,
man.
They're doing a levity out there.
They're going to do a levity out in a,
in that area now.
They really,
yeah,
yeah.
I saw it the other day.
I was driving by,
maybe they'll let me do the one that's 20 minutes from my fucking house.
Are you going to live here again?
No.
There's one.
I live in Westchester County,
New York.
I thought you meant out of here and you go over it.
You know,
you go over the Tappan Zee Bridge.
It's literally the levity live there right at the malls.
Like 22 minutes from me and I haven't done a weekend yet.
Never.
Nope.
How dare they,
they have problems that I'm doing.
One in January,
finally,
Jesus Christ,
levity live.
Oh,
you're booked in January but,
but for the first time I should've done it eight times.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
Fucking I'm going to gonna it Wednesdays there,
which is what have you been in that?
Well I haven't been there dude.
Great.
I went over there,
gone out.
Jesus.
That's what we need.
Another club in a mall.
You walk in there it is fucking gorgeous.
It's the sound system is as good as anything I've ever talked into them my life.
And it's just a gorgeous club.
Wow.
Plugging you guys.
Thank you guys that didn't cook me for three years.
You're welcome.
Best sound system I've ever heard in a club or any place is um,
that Terry Fator theater at the Mirage everybody performs.
If it's a over 400 seats,
I don't know about Diaz was on stage and I was in the back of the room and I
could hear him crystal clear cause then you know they designed that for the
Terry Fator guy.
The a ventriloquist.
If you're a ventriloquist like,
cause we have to have a post sound is super important.
So did the whole room was just like sound engineered.
It's amazing.
I never thought of that before.
So like a club like laugh Boston had a problem when they first opened.
They fixed it.
I worked there and it was great,
but before they had like an acoustic problem.
I think you told me that somebody told me that and they fixed it till he was
Ari.
I think it was our,
he may has already told me I had never worked there,
but Ari,
Ari worked there in the beginning it was like,
you know some problems here like people are struggling to hear shit.
Yeah.
That's the worst.
If you ever done a gig like that.
Oh Yeah,
you've done like those Lausanne comedy gigs,
the Improv's I can Pittsburgh.
You could hit fungos in there and fucking practice punting and you couldn't hit
the ceiling.
They like the key to a good comedy club and how people who opened comedy clubs
don't know this at this point because comedy club's been around for fucking ever
is a low ceiling.
Yes.
The first thing you want.
It keeps the energy in the room,
in the climate space and the audience's faith.
That's the first thing you do.
I get to the Improv a couple of years ago,
I couldn't,
somewhere in Pittsburgh.
I fucking,
I'm like,
hello,
hello.
I sounded like Lou Gehrig during that speech when he's,
I'm the luckiest man,
man.
Man.
On the face of the earth there are therapists and they couldn't understand me.
Joel,
between my Boston accent and between the fucking echo in,
it was like I was playing to like,
you know,
a 400 Guatemalans.
They just staring at me going,
oh,
and understand this person doesn't it?
Then I just go,
Jack Lambert,
the whole crowd would go nuts.
It's the worst one.
They can't hear you.
It's the most frustrating thing,
but one of the most frustrating things about being a comic.
How about when you can't hear yourself but the monitors aren't working or
something?
It's like talking into a dead microphone that really fucking scream a whole
show.
I did a show in Vegas once we're had to scream because they couldn't hear me
because it was such so echoy in stem here.
Ah,
by the time I was done I was like,
can I get him to have a voice anymore?
But sometimes when the monitor and you can't hear yourself,
you tend to talk louder,
but they can hear you.
Right.
Maybe that was a two.
Yeah.
That happens too though.
People like,
what do you,
why is he yelling?
Screaming to the Bachelor party once and I had like a little carry on a speaker
with a little tiny,
like a one of those things that you would plug into your guitar to practice
medicine.
That was the,
but they had a speaker or they had a cord that was plugged into it and this
really tinny microphone and I'm standing right in front of the guys.
They're like,
right where you are and I'm holding a microphone.
I'm like,
why do I even have a microphone?
You guys are right here.
This is the most ridiculous fucking show of all time.
Just standing in a bar in a basement somewhere in Boston doing comedy,
holding a microphone,
looking at guys right in front of me with,
you know,
my voice is loud.
Sounds still didn't you deal Gig,
you did a Gig,
one of those Boston gigs.
That was one of those,
there was a disco or they would clear out the date.
Quincy.
Yes.
A fight with somebody there.
No,
probably not.
Not any punches thrown.
That was the rumor.
The rumor was that no,
I beat the shit out of somebody.
No,
I've been to fight and we talked about this last time.
I've been at two fights in my life and and on as far as comedy and they were
both at clubs called giggles.
What was in cs and what was in Saugus mass.
They had nothing to do with each other.
That's just,
that's telling you something then,
you know,
I shouldn't be at a place called giggles,
but uh,
yeah,
but I know the one you're talking about.
I had heard the Quincy,
it was a one night or we all did it and like you said,
the people be dancing and shit.
All a sudden you have the needle go across the record.
That's all.
And all sudden did,
did,
did put a bag over the crystal ball that spinning over the dance floor and here
comes Joe Rogan and people are still dancing the fuck him,
you know,
they turn off,
they wouldn't even tell the people is a comedy show.
Hey,
they didn't even know that there's going to be a comedy show and you're up to
how I have talked to like fucking hell.
We want a dance.
It's so stupid.
They did.
So many of those good comics would do it.
I remember Jonathan Katz talking about
Barry Crimmins and we all know the money.
If you need the money and you lived in Boston,
it's an easy gig.
You drive an hour,
you make 200 bucks.
That's right.
And you could do and the 80s,
you could do Christ's like a 18 months in,
I was closing two or three rooms on a Friday night,
coming home with six,
$700 in cash.
It was crazy,
man.
I mean there was so many outside booking agents between Billy Downs,
Barry Berry.
And,
uh,
then there was a,
there was a bunch of other smaller ones and it was like Sherry Hirsch and normal
the foe.
They had gigs like in western Massachusetts,
John Schuler,
if you wanted to go to Connecticut and everybody,
like Boston comedy had so many fucking rooms,
man,
every pub.
And when people always ask me that when I started out at every pub and
restaurant in New England,
not just Massachusetts,
you can look at my book.
My first year I'd be at like a ski lodge in Burlington,
Vermont on Monday night,
Tuesday night,
a Chinese restaurant in Providence,
Rhode Island,
Wednesday night back in the city.
It stitches,
you know,
Thursday at a Mexican restaurant in Franklin,
Massachusetts asset.
If you ever talked to Louis Ck,
he's got them all memorized.
He can tell you.
Oh yeah,
he still remembers him.
I remember Mike Clark Colomy.
I've been in the business about eight months.
It's snowing like a bastard.
I'm living on Comm Ave in Boston and shitty apartment.
Mike calls me one in the afternoon.
He goes,
you want to do a Gig in new London,
Connecticut.
I look outside,
there's a blizzard.
The snow was blowing sideways.
We've already got like 11 inches.
Oh go.
Yeah,
he goes,
you want to work?
My brother Lenny,
you know Lenny was our idol then and I'm like,
I'm fucking,
I'll be there
talking about a three hour drive and it's blizzard.
I get there,
it's,
it's main Lenny and his nine people in the audience.
And the guy goes to Lenny,
I need an hour out of you,
like real sternly.
And Leonie's like,
okay mother fucker.
He starts to get going to me and then we're sitting at the table and he goes to
the,
the guy that owns the play,
he goes,
Dick,
come on,
sit down over here about two minutes in the compensation lending and knocks a
cup of coffee over on.
And I know he did it on purpose.
It's so intentional because he knocks it on,
you know,
he knocked on the guy that's gonna make them do an hour and he was like,
oh sorry,
Jesus Christ.
And he's laughing lens laughing at me and then land it goes on and does an hour
without taking a break.
Like,
there was 600 people there.
I mean,
I was,
this is,
that's when I was like,
oh my God,
it's a headliner.
He didn't take a break.
It was one 60 minute run on sentence and he murdered those nine people.
I couldn't even figure out how to get the mic out of the stand.
Joe is one of those clip Mike's.
I'm like,
I can think comes unplugged.
That's hilarious.
And Lenny goes on and just,
just,
I go,
oh my God.
That's how it's done.
And just,
and I don't mean working the audience,
I mean an hour of jokes in front of like nine people.
That was that style of comedy too.
Like Lenny embodied that style,
that fucking attack style comedy.
You know,
that there was,
Lenny was one of the,
well,
the first guys that I ever worked for,
I worked for,
um,
uh,
Warren Mcdonald.
I opened up for him.
Yes.
I opened up for him in like a chickopee mass.
That's George,
his older brother.
Yeah.
George McDonald,
who was a open mic night guy when I was coming up with Mike,
he was the host.
Oh Christ.
Wow.
That guy's been,
yeah,
it said comedy hell on the settlement side.
Stitches for us now I pulled up,
I saw the marquee.
Ugh.
That was a cool little room to that little room.
Only fat.
Like w w what would that fit like a hundred,
125 people at the most.
What a great little room
I was opening for.
Uh,
uh,
Lenny had his own show on Friday night there.
And um,
this is when I was going back and it's my second year and I had just moved down
to New York.
I had moved down when New York,
I was driving back and forth.
We had an apartment,
me and Louie down here.
I had to go back to stitches.
I took the train back and the train was late and shit.
So I'm,
I'm late getting stitches.
It's Lenny show and Kenny Rogers since like the middle and Shit can imagine.
I'm the rookie on the show.
I get there late.
Kenny's already on.
Oh No,
they uh,
like furious.
So I go out stitches a had a little ticket booth.
That's how you entered the stage from the ticket?
Both on the side.
So I go out there,
I don't have more than 20 minutes.
Right.
Joe,
at that point,
I don't have 20 good minutes.
I run out of material.
I'm like,
good night everybody.
I go,
good night.
I got to go off stage.
That door's locked.
So now I'm up on a stage.
I can't get out.
The only way I can get out,
jump off the front of it.
If your audience is staring at me,
the door's locked.
They won't let me.
So I go back to the microphone and it's not going.
So what do you do for a living?
Oh my God.
They wouldn't unlock the top like five minutes.
And then I went over to the,
I go,
come on guys.
And now the audience is laughing at me and shit.
They Kenny,
right?
It's an open door.
He goes,
fucking be on time on the fucker.
Uh,
that was a lesson.
Those road gigs were often hazardous.
Is that where you did the,
you're open Mike.
Your first one.
It stitches.
Yeah.
That was my first time.
August 27th,
that was Jonathan Katz.
He was the host.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's wild.
I did it the spring before and I remember,
um,
uh,
fuck man.
A couple really good comics went up that night to like guys that were local guys
who go in town do the open mic like pros but the big one,
well there was a couple of big ones but um,
teddy bears.
Ron was the biggest one.
Teddy bears one slayed it so smooth as silk.
And I remember being just a raw sort of rough first day ever opened.
Mike,
you can't get any rar.
I remember watching teddy bears.
Ron just going,
fuck,
he's so smooth.
He was just so slick.
Yeah,
he would hook.
It's right.
He would mc the,
some of the open mikes and stitches and he'd go on as a character called Allston
Brighton,
which is the two towns outside of an
English accent.
And I'm going,
this guy was on a tonight.
Joey sucks.
He was just doing some character.
Hello.
That got to be,
I had stitches and just do the shitty jobs on purpose and I'm going,
this guy was on a tonight cause you,
you don't know anything about comedy.
Then I go,
how the fuck is this guy?
And been on it with Johnny Carson and I go,
who is it?
He he'd go on his walls.
I thought his name was Austin Brighton for the first six months.
And then I see him at next one night.
Get like a standing ovation.
Yeah.
You see him to real.
I was real act and I was like,
oh my God,
I know nothing about what I do.
Did you ever see his tonight show set?
Yes.
Fucking yes.
Oh yeah.
One of the best tonight show sets ever.
Yeah,
it's in that mobile.
You wouldn't stand up stood out.
Well they show,
I'm sitting down I think in that movie,
but yeah.
And then he just went off the rails.
But when,
when he was in his prime is when nick and I,
nick was like,
you were like a little bit ahead of me like maybe a year,
I think.
Uh,
I know you something like six months to a year,
months.
I did the spring of 87 was my first open mic.
So we were,
we were both there when teddy was in his prime,
like when he was just hot and fucking,
just smooth and just would go up.
Right.
He had this style,
this was so casual.
And if there was a lot of guys,
like Lenny had this amazing style of I'll fucking attack.
Ah,
right.
And it was just Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
Right.
But Teddy would go up and make it look so effortless.
He was the only one.
You're right.
That wasn't doing that Boston attack.
He had his own,
he was a little more evolved.
He was so good.
But the alcohol is what,
uh,
pills,
alcohol,
the whole deal,
whatever it was that grabbed them.
I did one night with him and the hawks,
right.
And I get there and I'm opening for him some restaurant,
like in a hot,
and then he comes in and I,
I bring him up and as I'm coming off the stage,
he goes,
I'm double parked.
Move my car.
So he gives me his keys and I go out and I move his car and I come back in and
I'm watching them and I'm having a few drinks and then I get my car and I go see
this girl in land that I was seeing at the time.
And uh,
I call and check my answering machine messages,
you know,
at my house and Wilbon my apartment and it's a bit,
uh,
Nick,
teddy bears.
Yeah.
It's uh,
the show ended an hour ago or you have my fucking keys,
my car keys.
I left with this case
now the messaging was like eight messages.
He's now now and he's a horrible,
like alcohol will kill this guy.
So the next piece,
it's like 40 minutes late and nick,
if fucking Asshole,
I'm fucking you still at the fucking club.
Oh my God.
I had to fucking,
uh,
you know,
find him and get him his keys.
But he left like six messages and he was getting more drunk.
I played them over and over for comics.
I know he couldn't even talk.
It's like four of them.
While I was with this girl who I wanted to bang for years,
you know,
and I fucking,
after the first few metric,
I'm not leaving it for another round.
I go,
he's fine.
He's in the [inaudible] and the poor bass who was stranded,
they're told,
I don't know.
I could go up to them and three in the morning,
man,
maybe it was good that you didn't give praise.
Drove drunk.
Yeah.
He wasn't drinking.
No.
When I left I think I drove him to drink.
You know what I mean?
Cause he hates message.
You can hear him getting worse.
Can you imagine?
And I'm fucking sitting there and you know I didn't check my messages for a
while after I got that girl's apartment.
That's my Teddy Burger on store.
I missed that disco gig.
The disco Gig had already
closed by the time I was getting paid.
I heard about it when I was doing open mics and the Quincy Yance flow one that
you've gone.
I did one that was in the waiting room of a restaurant and the Co,
the standup Mike,
it was a Mike Clark Gig,
you know,
it was a one time only.
It was only me one man show and they canceled it right after I did it.
I called Mike as soon as I got home,
it was the most ridiculous thing.
The PA system was attached to the standup microphone and it was a big fish
restaurant down the Cape so that there was this big waiting room of people.
So you'd be on the stage.
So I'm saying there's no way we can do this.
And Les Johnson Party attune Treading Johnson party too.
And the first time he did it,
I just went,
no fucking way.
This can't be real.
And it was so ridiculous that the audience just started laughing.
Like whereas I was probably bombing before,
that probably wasn't going so well because it was just,
nobody knew there was going to be a comedy shock.
I had a band,
the band stopped and then really of that,
I never did that.
I don't even know if,
I don't remember if they introduced me,
my memory fucking blows.
Sometimes I can get,
I get like real crystal images of rec.
Really important shit.
Well there are times like when you told me that I ran after you in the car,
I was like God,
I was swore I called them.
Now you see you got me up on the way to the car.
Yeah.
But now that you say it,
now I know that I ran out and now,
but when I'm like why did I have that stupid fake memory in my head?
Cause I remember you were running out and I'm going off.
Fuck,
is he going to yell at me?
I must have fucking blown this audition.
I think dreams kind of fuck with your past memories because I dreamt something
once a long time ago and I remembered that I had told somebody about this dream
and then I forgot that that was,
that was real,
wasn't real.
Cause I,
I say I was talking about my friend and I was like,
oh yeah.
And she,
she works I think at this place downtown and I'm like,
wait,
no,
that's something I try weed man,
you guys don't,
no,
not at all.
I know.
I remember so much shit.
I remember when it wipe it off completely,
but I remember way too much sugar.
I think a short term though,
for sure.
No doubt about it.
Fucks with a short term.
We can be talking about something and I'll go,
what did we just say?
Like there's like blips of missing information,
but I think that those blips exist because there's a vacuum created by all this
new shit that's flying at you and I think the new shits find out,
you know,
if you're still trying to hold onto your thought,
you just had a couple moments ago,
you're resisting the Zen of the experience of the marijuana.
So if you just relax,
it's funny because I,
it's a catch 22 of me because I,
I'm having,
I have insomnia,
I have a fucking horrible time.
It doesn't matter what time zone I'm in,
what planet,
what state?
If I go to bed,
I wake up two hours later.
You wake up angry and complaining?
No,
I feel good.
I feel rested at for that,
for that moment,
but I'm not going to get up.
It's only four in the morning,
right?
Two,
I try to go back to sleep and I'll wake up an hour and a half later and I'll
wake up at eight and then not.
And I feel horrible and it's affecting me on stage even now.
And when we just tell them stories are a couple of names.
I couldn't remember.
What were we talking about?
New Mood.
How I couldn't remember the actor's name,
you know,
and,
and uh,
it,
it's fucking weird.
But,
but,
but everybody's like,
yes,
he's smoked weed at all.
It'll put you to sleep.
But it also,
I know it does a number of your memory if you get into that,
get in the habit of doing it right.
Yeah.
Well,
I think if you did it every day,
all day,
it would definitely fuck you up a hundred percent.
But I think if you'd do it a little bit every now and again,
it's good for you.
I really do not need it every night.
To do.
You should do mountains.
Get Melatonin.
That's the first thing everybody's suggested.
Or exam t do it.
I've tried everything.
I've drank cat piss of fucking,
that's your problem.
That's what's keeping it a slug with caffeine.
Isn't it?
In a store keeping you solve?
Is that fucking anger?
No,
it's a,
have you ever have done all that shit?
Have you ever had that cat shit coffee?
You ever heard of that coffee called Kopi Lou os a cat shit or raccoons?
What's a civet?
It's like a Thai thing.
It's a good way to get to go any further with the conversation.
I'm all set.
Thanks.
I'll stick these people's Sanka
[inaudible] brothers two words.
Sankoh's one
perfect.
Uh,
what?
Jesus Christ,
that is so fucking funny.
Same number.
Sancocho I do the,
um,
the,
there's this animal called civic eats the coffee beans and then shits them out.
And when it goes through its digestive tract,
the digestive enzymes break down the outer layer of the coffee
for that is called the coffee filter.
I don't need it to go through a fucking cat's ass fucking feline cunt.
You're missing the points.
Sure.
Digestive enzymes.
The cat's stomach make it a smoother,
smoother cough.
And this companies were in Liberia with this still wiping their ass of banana
leaves and rocks.
Okay.
They eat a bunch of cranberries and stuff.
Yeah,
that's the little animal.
Look at that little fucking,
if I were looking at the poop,
it looks like a,
what's that again?
Day by day.
It's how paydays are made.
That's a fucking payday bar.
See that being,
those beans have all been sort of strip.
Yeah,
I'm all set.
I'd rather have a Columbia guy crushing him with his bare feet.
So apparently their bodies don't digest the actual beans.
So they eat the outside.
The outside of a coffee bean.
I've read somewhere that green.
Uh,
there's like the,
the outside of like a friend,
like the juice from an actual green.
It's green beans.
Green before it.
Yeah.
And it was like a little red too,
but it's supposed to be really good for you.
Whatever that is.
Yeah.
I saw that on a doctor Oz and I actually ordered this shit.
It's supposed to help you lose weight.
Dr Oz mother fucker though.
I know.
I Google the motherfucker.
I said he's,
I said he's so handsome.
I have to go to,
they should know why you're mad at him.
The American Medical Association.
Very dead.
Yeah,
they got,
they got pissed at him that he had to go before Congress because of,
uh,
some fake diet pill.
He got shoned did he get on?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It was ugly.
But it's amazing.
You can get on that bear.
Yeah,
but that's just cause he's Oprah's bitch.
Yeah.
Somebody,
she won't have to Oprah.
And her day,
Oprah,
just spelling her lies,
starts peeling off numbers.
Ch,
ch,
ch.
You know,
what do we have to do to make this go away?
Go ahead.
She has to get Oprah's money.
Glad she went away.
Well,
she went away because she made more money than any human being ever and she's
like,
what the fuck's the point?
Do not.
Nobody wanted to hear from Randy Moore.
How would he even get ratings?
Fucking network.
Dare you and Victor.
Paula please fucking first of all these race,
these ratings are racist as a bunch of white males running that rating board and
they deny Oprah's real true rate.
It's probably would be the argument in court today.
They don't even know.
I don't think.
Do you think,
how am I,
how accurate do you think they really are at knowing ratings nowadays?
They're way more accurate because they're actually getting,
I heard they're actually getting numbers from a cable boxes and stuff nowadays.
Hmm.
Can they do that without your consent?
I liked the Nielson family myself.
It's probably in that,
that's a great big dude on tracked at the beginning when you turn on your cable
box and the Nielsons were like,
how many families?
And they were three.
They live right next to me.
Fucking loud,
obnoxious.
Always had the TVS on.
There wasn't that many people that did the,
when they did the knee,
they still do it right.
They still do it.
They have a Saturday where I just told her pretty sure at that they just knocked
on your door and so what do you watch that many families are?
They still do it.
I remember growing up,
my friend's dad was like,
I vice president was this big insurance company and they had one on their TV,
but it was kind of weird.
They had one.
Does it let this Leslie Nielsen,
let's say it's one of the families.
There's a,
that's a funny guy,
man.
Think about that guy.
That guy's entire life now.
300 homes.
1300 a piece,
Huh?
Okay.
Two largest local,
oh,
this is New York and Los Angeles will have their sample sizes increased by 300
homes next year.
About 1300 a piece.
So that's New York and Los Angeles is 2,600 this is in 2,600 homes of people,
but that's just a 2,600 homes in.
That's,
but that's just a in New York and La.
That's 51,000 Puerto Ricans right there.
How dare you,
how dare you and nick to call left coast.
Can't laugh at any of this shit.
Everybody just claimed fucking nervous lots.
It's turned into Mexico.
You're afraid to fuck in Lebanon.
Is that what it is?
It's just more liberal out here.
Right?
Do you think it's more liberal on here?
Do you feel the difference when you just stand that I,
well,
I haven't really done standup,
but just,
yeah,
just,
just going into her to at lax I can see it's much more liberal and going into
her hurts.
Oh,
hurt the car.
This know why.
What's going on then?
I don't know.
I didn't see anybody that spoke English.
She guide mumbling to me in some accent and it was right up.
The place was rudderless.
No fucking manager.
40 people in line,
three poopin people behind the counter and nobody taking charge.
Nobody that looked like me.
Nobody looked like you.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's DePaul a little just,
well now you can fucking live in this world and put up with that shit,
but you can't do it.
No,
I can do it.
You just saying you asked me.
No,
it's my renting me my fucking cars.
that's not what I'm saying.
Just let them just let the white guy fucking managers.
What's one thing we can do?
Oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
You guys,
when are you wake the fuck up?
Man,
the fuck up,
bro.
Car rental managers.
I'm just much more liberal.
I'm fucking kidding.
These are jokes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
don't we don't,
Oh yeah,
I forgot you had advertisers.
No,
not,
not right now.
Not Anymore.
What happened?
I don't.
I do them later.
A splice them,
man.
How are you doing?
You even,
you can have control over that.
Yeah.
I think this is the way to do it.
Absolutely.
Yeah,
because this way we just have a conversation,
you know the way,
the way,
the other way of like interrupting doing.
In the beginning it was always awkward because it gets to be sitting there and
I'd have to go through five minutes of stupid ads and then doing it in the
middle was always out of the question,
so now we'll just do it.
This who you way
it looks like in 2005 Nielsen started using things like Tivo and cable boxes and
stuff like that and even finding when people turned off a shows,
they even know how accurate as if they the first commercial break if people left
the show.
So it's super accurate now.
That's some big brother type shit right there.
It's weird.
I mean,
just the only way to find out really is you got to do that and why does it
bother us?
Because it doesn't bother us when you see like youtube hits.
No.
If you put up a youtube video and it gets 17 million units,
well it's all right there.
You could see it.
17 million heads.
Yeah.
They don't want you to know the numbers.
Yeah,
it's deigned.
It's weird and radio,
it's hard to get numbers real hard to get numbers and Rachel,
they don't want you to know that you could be making them a ton of money.
They're going,
no,
you only have 70 listeners.
This is why we don't think they know when it comes to radio,
like that Arbitron book.
I think that is just that.
The whole thing's a mess.
They keep changing it.
Now they have things.
People walk around with a clip,
done it their belt mid,
supposed to click it.
If it listening to it.
That's so stupid.
They're not going to click that and exactly what they do.
They're assholes anyway.
You don't want them.
Exactly.
You're wearing that,
I don't want you as the listener unless you're getting a lot of money for that
dude.
Let's say,
give me like 500 bucks a week to whether it's stupid thing.
I don't know why you would wear that.
So it could be like a Shizam based thing,
you know,
like,
so as things are playing,
you listen to it,
but even then,
you know what I mean?
Like Shizam like picks it,
you know,
that's that APP.
Do you know of?
No,
I don't.
It's great.
Like if there's a song playing and you don't know what it is like with the
phone,
you hold it up and it tells you,
tell you like instantly.
And my wife told him,
it's so crazy.
Like it doesn't even make sense that it works and it works so well.
Like you look at it happening,
you can go on.
That is,
it's instant.
It just knows the beat they should have that.
If you're in a nightclub and you're gonna
pick up a chick,
you hold it up to her as if she's fucking crazy.
And I tells you her,
I killed her work that way.
But if they could tell you your heart rate from x box one,
imagine if you could fucking put it in front of a girl and just tell you how
crazy she is.
Can you give me like a one to 10 just scans your body and let's see now like
look,
look what's going on in her head as a fucking pink pong game of different
personalities and throwing balls at each other.
Let's go home.
We're religious,
I'm a child of God.
Let's suck his cock.
Just trying to figure out which way to go.
Always completely unstable.
If they could find out your heart rate,
that would mean how the fuck are they finding out your heart rate,
but looking at you on some screen,
unless you're wearing a device,
must be wearing a device.
Are you wearing anything?
It's thermo.
I think it's got three cameras pointing at you and they're all different because
that's not just like a regular video camera.
So the three cameras pointing at you,
what are they reading?
Tons.
Thermal.
The others like this where you are displaced in the room,
but it's reading,
reading,
like heat.
Really waging that into us.
It's an APP or talking about Xbox one.
So,
uh,
if it's gauge and heat,
do you have to program in how warm your room is?
How much you weigh,
how big you are?
It can tell he knows when you've been sleeping and it's tons of little quick,
tons of little dots over you.
So it reads like it's super accurate.
Like it can read your hands,
like going like this,
you know that accurate?
It's pretty at the new one.
Xbox one.
What the fuck man,
I'm missing out on all this.
You could easily get an x.
He should have an Xbox one.
Should I use the last time you watched the last UFC on the next box one and it
was so easy.
It's just like order through expo.
I'm moving towards doing less shit.
That's what I'm moving towards.
I'm not moving towards doing anything more.
This is,
I'm enjoying relaxing lately.
That's a lost art.
You know,
everybody's hustling going by.
I had your money fuck up and relax.
And 10 years ago,
what'd you have?
Oh yeah.
What you been doing?
What would you do?
Who should I do?
You could be smoking pot and floating in my pool.
Ah,
there you go.
Big Margarita and a pool and that was,
I don't want smoke pot changed that answer.
You should have a fishing pond,
Joe.
I have a part on a canoe and fish and smoke weed all day.
That's right.
That day.
No seriously.
That sounds perfect.
Fun Day thing of Heinekens in between your legs.
Isn't it funny that you're alone?
Like nobody gives a fuck if you kill a fish.
You know people don't care about fish.
But if there was like,
like uh,
like wild game preserves near four seasons in Hawaii and dudes were coming in
and like gutted Mousse or something like that,
people would freak the fuck out.
You can come with a Marlin big 1500 pound Marlon.
Nobody gets a shit.
Delicious.
Very tough.
It is.
It's very delicious.
But it's just weird that we don't,
we don't give a shit if someone kills efficient front of us.
Like we have like very clear hierarchies and it's not even about the size of the
animal.
It's about whether or not the animals cute.
Like if you have like a squirrel,
you kill a squirrel in front of a p,
they'll fuck people freak out if you kill a squirrel.
But people eat squirrels.
A lot of parts of the world,
people eat squirrels.
But if you kill a tuna in front of them,
like a 500 pound tuna does it.
Most people don't even bat an eye weird.
Right.
I hate that.
And you see like a Japanese cutting goof fans off sharks?
Yeah.
Is it the Japanese?
It's the Japanese show.
Yes.
Don't get all nervous.
I can make it up.
Do you see that surfer with the shark on live TV?
I'm not saying we should kill all the sharks.
They cut the fins off them though.
And let the,
let the rest of the fish drown.
Did it'll get eaten nine nine one one to 10 it's a good thing.
But they use,
they using it for aphrodisiac,
making soup with it and shit.
Well I think it's just delicious.
Shark's fin soup.
I think the aphrodisiac is like the horns like Rhino Horn,
right?
How your Dick Tiger Dick Tiger Dash.
They do something with tigers.
I don't know if it's tiger deck,
but I can,
that is fucked up though.
They cut the fins off and just jumping in the water and they let him fucking
drown.
What's kind of sociopathic?
Yeah.
It's kind of creepy behavior.
Replace the fence if you're going to take it,
put a fake one on.
Yeah.
Not only that,
like when can you use that meat for something like he's selling the shark meat,
pet food or something like that.
Sure.
You know,
I mean it's probably good protein.
Like why would you just let it all go to waste like that?
That seems so silly.
And then there's the numbers,
like how many they kill.
They kill a lot.
You get that shark fin soup.
You got to kill a lot of fucking sharks.
But that surfer video is ridiculous.
Yeah.
Oh God.
It's terrifying that I'm surprised you didn't see like a,
you know him shitting his pants all over the board.
It's amazing.
He didn't get bed.
I mean that thing is thrashing around and that was a big fin.
Big fucking with no little Maaco Shark.
What if that was a shark shark?
That was like a 10 foot shark,
right?
If your guests,
the nine 10 foot,
how big did they think it was Jamie?
I didn't.
I didn't see it seemed like it was like a 10 foot shark,
but it's definitely big enough to fucking kill you.
Hell yeah.
Why does surfers and not carry weapons on him?
Like why don't they have like a a like some kind of Taser or something that they
can wear around their neck and it in emergencies.
Pop it off.
It should have an APP for that.
I know.
Maybe it will help you.
You know how you wrote like a lot of guys they'll paddle board out there if
there's like a new sport and just like with a spear.
I think sharp.
Yeah,
because like you draw the sheriffs,
you fucking Miss Dude.
That's a good show.
Pitch.
That one pitch that well you could do,
you can probably get away with doing it if you did it with chain mail.
If you had some sort of a fine chain mail shark suit on,
he could probably get away with doing that.
But you know to see whether or not you got bit,
he knows what a bad ass paddleboard or you would have to be to take that risk.
I fuck dude,
that could go wrong.
Yeah.
That would be enough to keep me out of the wine the rest of my life.
Well,
that was in South Africa.
Right?
South Africa is one of the worst spots worlds for a shark attacks about North
Carolina.
This year they will walk on up on shore and biting people.
Richmond covers makes waves with homemade cage.
Oh,
I
saw those people.
These people walked out with a shark cage on it.
Looks like a birdcage.
Yeah.
Not bad move.
Got 'em on TV.
That's a six,
five or six foot.
Great White.
By the way,
it was only six foot.
Oh Wow.
That's big enough.
Yeah.
That's plenty big to fuck you up.
You know you are sharks,
man.
What a crazy animal that guy's face.
Yeah.
I'd rather be bitten by the shark,
I think.
Well,
I got,
was that John Madden's gay son?
One thousand one thousand I don't think you'd get away from me.
What a great idea.
[inaudible] just such a strange animal.
Did the,
the Dave Dave got to a stage of existence where they just maintain the exact
same form for hundreds of millions of years.
It's all he'd been doing for hundreds of millions of year.
Like they never improved.
Like if they stopped swimming,
they drown.
It's a total shitty design.
They can't sleep.
They just swim around and Jack Things.
I can relate to that,
but that it's hilarious when you think about it.
Like it's a cleanup crew.
It's like literally like the cleanup crew for the ocean.
That's why I can't stop.
It's not allowed to do what it wants to do.
We can't just gorge itself and then just chill out.
No one has to keep moving or it done.
What a fucking bummer.
What a bomber existence.
You've got to keep moving ahead called Kansas time for that fucked all as a term
for when you have to keep moving.
Tony Soprano had it.
Oh,
perpetual motion.
You have to keep moving.
Is that a perpetual motion?
Trying to,
I forget how many people pretended to be Italian after this.
Pronto's so large percentage.
I don't know.
The good fellas.
Yeah,
all those movies.
It's amazing how many mob movies are,
it's really think about like the amount of movies made about the Italians.
The one guy just died from a godfather,
right?
The uh,
she just died yesterday.
Two days ago.
Who's at fuck,
hold on from the Godfather.
You mean the movie and actor or an actual guy?
Marlin Brando.
A
verb or Berber.
Okay.
Alex rock star.
No,
that's Mo Green.
Oh,
green.
He fucking two days ago even look like him.
What's that supposed to be him?
Yeah,
that's him.
Ri while he looks at him and all that.
Mo Green.
Did he catch one in the,
I choked on a breadstick at the office.
Oh,
that's fucking racist,
man.
God,
Brian White.
Give me Wagga be you all have gotten when Italian chin,
he has a running joke about all garden.
It slips in all of garden into conversations.
I had the best chunk governor on the olive garden.
I can't remember.
Oh,
a bit.
I mean I would love to hear it and people.
You're the trucking Gogel I'll look at him.
My first algorithm in that bottom image.
That's when like right after he won the academy award.
Yeah.
Those are the glasses,
my green hat on when he got it.
Getting massage
does something great about those sweet Justin classes really go.
Yeah.
I believe he's a Boston guy.
Mo Green.
I did not hear that.
Very good theory is that looks more like more grain there.
That's it.
We all go.
Everybody's,
Hey Michael,
how you doing?
I mean,
all,
we're not going anywhere.
You're going to be okay.
Oh Christ.
What's going to one 10,
one 11 before I go?
Really?
Oh Shit.
I'll start shitting my pants about a week from now.
But what makes you say that?
I'm kidding.
He 90,
I'll be gone.
So yeah,
but you gotta stay in it.
You gotta put,
you got to call again.
What's it called again?
That's a extreme in my mind's not even know.
This one's been out a few years to yeah,
30 minute insanity or whatever.
And anyone,
you know what I'm talking about t I've seen the commercial.
Uh,
definitely say the commercial is working out.
He's jumping around for 30 minutes.
I don't know how you can talk and still,
you know,
doing that type of Rebecca decide so it's still been able to speak.
You got to get a fit.
Unbelievably fit.
Yeah.
When you're demonstrating moves,
like if you don't,
your martial arts moves,
you get exhausted.
Like what could talk and you know,
throwing kicks and you're trying to explain what you're doing.
You get very good,
real quick talks nonstop for 30 minutes while he's jumping around and it's,
people give up.
Like there's,
there's people that have to sit out like halfway through there.
Absolutely.
Why you picked some really fucking Weirdo.
It's a lot of time.
It really is hard.
But how about the,
there's another girl out there,
autumn,
Autumn calibrates her name?
No,
she's a beach body.
One of those.
Tony Horton.
Probably Chaise and um,
just Google autumn calibrates and she's got the 20 to 21 day fix out of
something.
Tom,
it's an infomercial at Tom Bergeron,
but you should see it.
Look at a body on it.
I've,
I've never seen anybody who doesn't juice or isn't a bodybuilder.
You kidding me?
She and shaped fit.
She looks very fit.
Unbelievable.
30 minute workout though.
What is her Jane Fonda's?
It's really easy.
School is,
it doesn't evolve.
One of the things you hold onto this whole shake,
shake weight
fucking exist.
Hence the most ridiculous workout tool ever.
She grab onto somebody is having a seizure.
It's hard to find someone as a seizure when you were trying to get work out of
it.
What was Suzanne Somers one?
The one that you put in between they have vibrating five mass.
I bought a used one and licked it but 20 minutes.
Do you know,
I know a Jujitsu guys who got the thigh master so that they could work the
inside leg muscles.
So they get squeezed guys buys,
is that right?
But they have info commercials with Jane Fonda.
Get off your bullshit?
No,
for real.
Is it a merger with a coffee?
It's probably the coffee but they have a infant commercial that Jane Fonda with
vibrating the vibrating workout thing and it's what some of the funniest shirt
is linear.
It is thighmaster I bought a used one on Ebay.
So then would it smell like I sniffed it for like an hour and set it back?
Not Acceptable.
Yeah.
It smells like pineapple.
Find me one that's been used by an American.
That's the new Hitachi right there.
I'm not playing around with your goddamn coconut thighmaster
for sexy hips and thighs.
Oh my God.
What the hell is that?
Oh Gel
and off to the infomercial.
Bronzing Gelatin.
Hilarious ties together and then orange them.
Exactly how our girls using this to masturbate because it has to be for that,
right?
Not,
I guess you could get everything warmed up first with that.
I'll give you,
you were hell bent on stimulating or simulating some sort of a wild gorilla fuck
fest.
Will you do is you just squeeze the shit out?
I think to your legs reach fatigue and you know all the while you've got to like
play with yourself and then once you realize that your legs are about to give
in,
that's when you start shoving the dildo inside you.
I'm not saying you should do this.
I'm just saying that's how I would handle it.
I just heard shoving the deal done with yourself.
That's all I heard out of that.
I was just thinking if you really wanted to have,
uh,
you know,
if you want to use the thighmaster four orgasms,
if you were trying to master it with it,
that'd be the only way to use it to make your legs tired unless you turn it on.
So it's like this,
like a pyramid,
like the balls at the top and then you put it down and the girls sit on it and
pushed down.
Like they tried it,
like vibrates.
That's probably what they're doing.
It was back to you.
Yeah.
And he bronze.
The bronze is actually in Gel.
We put it between the legs and have their husband stick the head and then they
clamp it on their husband's neck.
You know what I know,
like,
I don't like that.
Those,
Oh my God,
facts are sometimes made up fake.
Half of them are fake.
Sometimes they're made up because there was one about the vibrators.
The vibrator was the second or third,
you know,
of the uh,
electronically connected things,
electrically powered,
uh,
things from the,
in the household.
I was like,
what?
And they're like,
it beat the washing machine and something else.
And I was like,
wait a minute.
That's the third most what I used to know the one of the quickest created like
one of the,
the third oh,
rarely third electric creation.
That's probably bullshit invention.
Yeah.
It was probably came up with Edison's wife.
Even say it like you're delivering a pledge.
Like
they used to have those in doctor's offices.
They used to stimulate women to orgasm and doctor's offices.
That was a a normally mean used to go to the right doctor,
the right dentist,
not a laughing gas and just how many say me?
I have philosophy.
We talked since the Cosby thing.
Oh come on.
That's,
he's fine.
This is a racist society trying to pull down another black man,
Joe.
That's what I never raped anybody,
man.
Why you getting all over his shit?
Chuck for public
enemy who I love dearly on his a Twitter thing.
He called him a doctor,
Cosby doc.
Extra Huxtable cheat.
You know what actually he is a doctor in real life,
but he's a,
he's an honorary.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah,
but I think they rescinded that or did they take that and they take that back?
They took something back,
took some honorary something or another.
He had back,
I don't know if it was that,
but then they built a stone statue of him in front of Grambling there.
What?
She Tampa,
there's so many funny things that Cosby did in the past that now are a lot more
funnier now because of all these,
you know,
like he,
like when coke two came out,
there was a commercial and I forget what the tagline was.
Oh,
I know.
Saying it's like trust me and he's like holding.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
Yeah.
And then like,
there's like a Cosby show where he makes Chili and goes down and I have my
special ingredient that makes you go get sleepy and then like he walks into like
Rudy huck look,
the kids are like eating the chili was like no,
really,
really says I have my special ingredient.
There's a car now when you watch them in retrospect,
they fit that narrative perfectly.
Oh my God.
So now I've been just thinking of like every single Cosby movie I wanna Watch
now and find like all the secret things.
Like what was the one where he was like a,
it was a one where he's pulling a Putin pop out of it.
Unconscious girl's ass.
What movie was up by like going through like old fat and stuff and
so funny.
Guilty.
What was co thank Gail fucking t.
There was a commercial for coke to that.
I've got a fine,
that seems like a tough one to argue.
I didn't like pause button.
Have it like this.
I'm a pretty,
I respected,
but I never found the phonic.
When I was working at Chris Rock,
the whole show went to see Cosby and I didn't want to go.
Really?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
We're going to see him in Vegas.
I'm going to take a trip to Vegas just to see him because everybody was telling
me like,
you got to see him,
that he's the best.
You got to see him.
They were saying,
they were saying like he sets up these bits and they're just fucking perfect and
I felt that way about Jay Charbonneau.
J Sharma,
a name from the pile.
You just hurt my feelings.
Stitches.
I forgot about.
He was the angry guy that I loved him.
He's always angry.
Holy Shit.
How do you maybe potty is fucking with my memory if you can,
bro.
All these fucking with your memory.
That's been proven.
It hasn't been proven on Fox News.
No,
Not Fox News.
Pauly shore.
His mom put crisis.
That's,
I don't think she did pot.
No,
she'd probably be never touched a weight in your right.
First of all,
how dare you.
Second while I think it was some other stuff.
It was what?
It was genetic to Parkinson's.
Oh,
I was just throwing that out there.
I don't know.
She had a dizzy.
Yeah,
she does know.
she's had been ill for a long time.
I think she's got parking either Parkinson's or muscular sclerosis.
I don't know what a or multiple sclerosis.
Multiple Sclerosis.
No,
I'm up.
I loved Mitzi.
She passed me the first night I showed up in La.
She was in the crowd choose and then in the original Rome and it was like open
mic or a new pot,
pot luck or whatever,
the fine like three guys on up and just ate their own shit.
Like Jay Leno had had the best set and he got like six labs,
j London and then I just fuck.
I went on and you know,
that's when I was doing it four times a night,
you know,
30 nights a month.
And she just happened to be there and she was fucking little.
Your hat was falling off.
She got that.
Adam,
do you guys,
you come in anytime you want the money.
She couldn't have been sweeter.
Do you miss living out here?
Uh,
I don't miss it,
but I,
in retrospect,
looking back,
I enjoyed it more than I thought I did.
And I mean,
you enjoyed it more than you thought it did when I first,
when I was so happy to get back to New York and I got in La at all,
but now they look back on and I had good times.
It wasn't bad.
No,
not bad.
There's,
there's definitely a difference in the vibe.
You know,
that's the,
the different vibe that you get when you're in La.
It's just,
it's just way different than the vibe that you get in New York and especially at
like comedy clubs,
The New York Comedy Club vibe.
It's like very hostile.
It's a different kind of vibe though.
The comedy cellar is like a tourist trap and really?
Yeah,
low Louise show is so popular.
People come from all over now and they see the comedy cellar,
you know,
they showed at the beginning of Lucia and like the early shows there are like
sometimes you like,
Whoa,
how did that joke,
swing and mess.
Then after the show,
the Dome,
I was like,
well that helped 14 people there from like fucking Sweden.
They're all German and uh,
that's like the early show that I guess the second and third shows it gets back
to,
but it's not hostile.
It's on the campus of Nyu.
It's all college kids and they have their brains filled,
you know,
PC,
Mush,
college kids.
His mother fucking know it.
All little punks.
Yeah.
Well Seinfeld's too edgy forum.
So we'll,
Seinfeld is a racially diverse.
He didn't diversify as cars and coffee show sounds racist.
Sounds racist.
Even their problem with him,
they think he's too Ed.
Hey Jamie,
there's a dude outside.
They don't want to bring in a,
it was a guy that I met last night.
I wanted to sit down with nick and I don't want to bring this guy in.
His name is screaming.
His name is Adam should be out there right now.
I can get this guy last night that is a counselor in Florida and uh,
I,
I have to leave tomorrow.
I was trying to figure out what way to,
uh,
to have this guy talked to me about what the fuck he did when I hear about scam,
a money scam,
a crazy money's cam.
This guy was,
uh,
working with,
drug rehabilitation people in Florida and like,
you know,
fucking dealing with people that have all these drug addictions and all the
different prescriptions that they would put them on and how much money they
would get.
He was telling me that they would charge the people like $1,500 a day to keep
someone,
a patient and their institution.
Can you set up a microphone over here?
Is that possible?
MMM.
Mixing it up.
Nick the Apollo.
Can I and watch I fuck,
yeah.
Nick,
dip.com.
What are you doing next?
We've got going on.
I don't know the out here for question.
I,
I'm still selling the album and I got such a kick after I did your show and
Adams and everybody else is out here.
I got a spike in sales,
so I thought I'd refresh it.
You're like a businessman.
You made a smart business.
Move out to la.
I did.
That's nice.
So,
you know,
uh,
do you ever need me to tweet anything?
I'd be more than half.
Seriously.
I shouldn't have said that.
I'll be hound me.
Give me a hard time.
But I uh,
yeah,
no,
I did a thing.
And Amy Schumer 12 angry men.
Oh yeah.
How was that act with Paul Giamatti and Jeff Goldbloom and John Hodge show is
smashing killer right now.
So,
uh,
you know,
things are kicking him.
She,
it's getting interesting because she's,
uh,
she's experiencing some backlash from some shit that she so said no,
people are mad at her now.
It's interesting.
It's a little fucking sick,
isn't it?
Joe Will,
what are we doing here?
They eat themselves.
Yet there was a final magazines.
You see the cover of the magazine with her sucking on a c three Po.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
we'll,
all these people were saying that like that's a,
an a front to feminism and people are mad at her now and you know,
it's,
it doesn't promote feminism for her to suck on a robot's file.
Exactly.
I mean the rate,
like you said,
they're eating each other,
but she did it and she did them Hispanic,
but it's not Hispanic people getting mad at her.
It's white liberal people.
Exactly.
I never have a problem with,
uh,
you know,
like minorities in the audience.
They never have her palm with my shit.
It's always white little liberal kids trying to defend the,
uh,
feelings.
Seriously.
Come on in and Adam,
come on and have a seat.
It's fucking embarrassing.
Well,
it's uh,
it is,
uh,
put those headphones on too,
if you would.
Yeah,
it's a fucking,
it's a real problem with comedy.
Comedy's a big part of what comedy is.
The same shit.
You don't really mean because it's the funny thing to say.
And if you're going to cut off that and you're gonna make it like really
difficult to people for people to express themselves,
honestly,
you're gonna get shittier and Shittier comedy,
you know,
you're going to have to only say what you mean always,
I say what I mean know and they have a problem with that toe that too.
But I mean even joking around about shit,
some things are clearly in just what's up dude pulled that thing up to your face
better,
their their works man.
So I met this guy last night,
he started talking to me about a co two will tell him,
tell him the whole story.
Which part of the Medicare part of those issues talk into the microphone.
Does he ever done a podcast for anything like this?
I wrote a book,
right?
Yeah.
And what's your of yeah,
two of those things man.
And what is the book?
The first one is mastering life transitions and the second one is a chemical
incarceration addicted to the process.
And so you were working with people that are drug addicted and you felt like it
was like a money scam.
It is.
I mean it's,
it's a process they set up to a you from,
from the beginning.
Uh,
I mean they bring you in for a 30 day rehab.
And what I'm talking about.
A government funded facilities,
you know,
medicare facilities,
they get you to come in and for 30 days they basically switch out whatever hard
drugs you're on with
their synthetic drugs.
Right?
Why they make,
you know,
the facility owners get $1,500 a day per patient inpatient facility,
and then they're discharged.
You're kind of pushed to say,
hey,
discharge them to our outpatient facility because then they make another five to
$700 a day per patient affordability of four to eight weeks.
How ridiculous is that government scam less government Joe?
Well,
it's government.
It's crazy because the patients want the drugs in the hospital,
but the hospital owners take care of the patients,
almost like their VIP clients at the Ritz Carlton.
That's so crazy.
Adam.
Tell everybody full name man.
Adam Lowry.
Yeah.
And uh,
what's the name of your book?
Um,
the second one is chemical incarceration,
addicted to the process.
The first one is mastering life transitions and it's all what is,
are they both on the same subject?
Uh,
no.
Mastering life transitions was,
I came up with my own theory,
uh,
is called Tsb t trans rational structure,
behavior theory.
Holy Shit.
Yeah,
that's what I said.
A whole bunch of psychobabble shit.
But uh,
then I summed it up to the cognitive rampage and that's essentially what I call
it,
the cognitive rampage.
Ah,
that's actually the website,
cognitive rampage.com.
Can I use that for a CD to cry man,
please man,
go ahead and fucking great name.
Cognitive rampage.
What w what's cognitive rampage and tail?
Well,
for me,
when I'm talking or I'm giving my delivery or I'm giving my speeches or whatever
I'm talking about,
I get really rampaging and I get intense.
I mean,
I'm trying to fucking help somebody's life.
You get all Donald Trump be like,
that's different.
That's different.
I mean,
I just got tired of that therapist that sit there and you will tell me how that
makes you feel and then,
you know,
treats you in some pump,
has manner and dance around you for a half and a fucking hour.
Hope and you figure some shit out.
So for people that get hooked on drugs and they get involved in some sort of
recovery program like that with the instantly take the drugs that they're on and
they put them on another drug that just has a similar effect.
But it's illegal.
I mean,
they really don't do anything.
No,
nothing.
That's,
that's common.
That's like with most of the time what happened?
That's period.
What happens?
What's crazy is you could walk into a drug treatment.
Now these are medicare funded now medicare,
not like passages in Malibu,
but not like that.
But if you walked in,
you're supposed to be greeted by a physician and diagnosed within the first day
or two.
Makes Sense.
What a cut costs.
You walk in and a high school graduate fills out your admission paper and throws
on your diagnosis.
Bipolar,
right.
You can't even diagnose anybody with that until they're off drugs until they're
back at baseline.
But you can't take them into your inpatient unless they have one of those labels
so they can get paid for.
Well,
there you go.
So the legal way of diagnosing someone's being bipolar,
you got to wait until they're free of all drugs.
That's right.
So they do it illegally.
And everybody knows,
everyone knows at the willow and Naples,
west government where I was fucking government.
Yes,
he's right in that and this sense,
right?
Like that's not,
at least it's keeping people off the streets,
I guess.
But how much money is being spent and it's all tax dollars,
right?
If it's Medicare,
oh,
all of it.
It's all of our money.
I mean,
what,
what's funny is the patients think it's their money.
So when they're sitting in the rehab,
it's,
Hey doc,
I need my pills.
Right?
Therapists,
you need to discharge me here and do this for me.
I'm a sense of their fucking travel agent.
I mean,
the book,
what I talk about,
addicted to the process.
What incentive does somebody have to quit doing drugs?
All right.
Let's say you have a very minimal education.
Nothing going for you.
Yeah.
I can quit doing heroin and cocaine and maybe go,
I don't know,
clean shit for a living or something,
but then I can't even have a drink to waste away that shit day I just had.
So what they do is they'll come into a 30 day treatment facility,
do their 30 days,
but its bed and breakfast.
It's drugs,
it's smoking,
it's sex.
Even in most of them.
Yeah.
They take away ambition,
government programs,
it's,
they do the bathrooms become fucking hostels.
It's crazy.
And then after 30 days by law,
I have to find them where they're going to live,
where they're going to get their next drugs from and how they're going to get
there and their doctor.
So it eliminates all the ambition they might have to get their shit together.
Completely enables him.
Wow.
That's insane.
Do you want to quit?
Would you want to quit?
I do.
30 days.
I was on heroin for a while.
Not me,
but let's say I was,
and I walk in,
I do 30 days.
I meet some new finance chicken AA meeting that sees life the way I do and we're
going to conquer this together so we get discharged to say,
I don't know,
I've always wanted to see Savannah.
Well by law I got a discharge and find their house,
find their doctor,
what we then fly them there or send them on a bus.
Then they go to outpatient facility four to eight weeks on our dime.
Again,
just to hang out with more people that don't want to quit party some more for a
while only to relapse and go,
well I guess a,
I'll admit myself to this savanna rehab.
Then do another 30 days come out and now they go,
well,
I've always wanted to go to Vegas.
Where's the ambition to get clean or the incentive and wealthy whizzy and
incentive to work.
You're going to go out and get a 40,000 a year job.
You can get that benefit.
Is this.
It seems like I would have heard of this.
That's why he freaked me out when we were talking last night.
Like it was after the show and I was talking to them when there's a bunch of
people around is dom I rare we're hanging out with and it was,
it was hard to like get a real bead on how deep this went,
just with all those other people around all that.
But what you're saying doesn't make any sense because it seems like,
not that I don't believe you,
but it seems like that would have been so obvious a long time ago.
That's a ridiculous way to do things.
You can't because if I'm like,
what would be a licensed therapist?
If I say anything I get blackballed from ever working at any facility again.
Oh my God.
No therapist after you go get $150,000,
you know,
a degree,
you got debt,
you've got to pay.
If you speak out against what's happening,
you're blackballed.
And that's it.
And all of these facility factors know each other.
Wow.
What's your,
what's your title?
You'll work title?
Well,
technically I can't say therapist anymore.
I'm not a licensed therapist cause fuck that.
I don't want it.
I gave it back and I don't believe in practicing and some conservative structure
change somebody's life.
Um,
and so it's just me with a master's degree.
Uh,
some life coaching stuff.
A freelance.
Okay.
What is your,
what is your degree in mental health counseling.
Wow.
What a trip that must be to be embedded in that system.
Like that dude,
it fucking killed me to be straight with you man.
Uh,
you know,
when I first got in I was,
cause I really changed my life from the shit I used to be in.
Turn it around,
show up,
ready to,
you know,
help people and get involved.
Only to see everyone around me corrupt.
They,
they've given the fuck up.
Wow.
That's so crazy that there's so much of a money grab going on.
I never had heard that before.
And nobody has a reason.
I mean,
the facility owners are making millions.
The people getting treatment or getting her drugs in,
uh,
in bed and breakfast place.
Why would they want to say anything?
Therapist can't say anything.
He'll lose his fucking job.
I want to do heroin.
Come on nick.
Let's,
uh,
let's do some heroin for a couple of months.
From what I hear is a box in as much better.
The synthetic stuff that we may say,
you're white.
She hit her on the corner of your mouth.
What is the box?
This is the other thing you were telling me last night.
They replaced the heroin.
The people come in,
they have a heroin addiction.
They replace it with suboxone,
but the differences that heroin is pretty cheap and suboxone is fucking really
expensive.
There you go.
Like what does the difference in the money?
Well,
now you can get suboxone pills on the street for 20 bucks to 40 bucks.
Depends on who has it and it's cheaper than your fucking copay.
Wow.
Your copay when you buy it from the pharmacist is more expensive than buying it
on the street many times.
It depends on your plan.
D So many pro tips.
So many protests.
Brian's ready to get out of here.
He's like,
I have felonies.
Jumped Brian's apartment,
new apartment,
nice and skinny heroine.
Chicken with their blue baby crawling on the ceiling.
Gray,
blue baby.
But you do want skinny heroine.
Get tastes in music.
Just tasteful tattoos,
some knuckle tattoos,
a shady pasts,
but she's good cuddler.
Have you been in a Rehab Jogi Oh,
I just said kind of.
I see the picture now.
Very,
very boot Koski 76 you can't go on 60 minutes or anything cause you'll be well
cast.
One of the owners I worked for actually,
he's already even been arrested for Medicare fraud in 1985 and he still owns
four hospitals today.
Mind maybe all of the people that you're learning this from our fraud.
And so you're just like outing all your bosses and they don't actually do this.
Oh well now my,
my boss,
my direct bosses.
Now Leo [inaudible] was my mentor manager.
Leo also mentioned names Bro.
Those listening.
He's a good dude.
But um,
this was in Florida.
Yeah.
So that's such a fucking whacked out state.
I,
is that like everywhere in the country or is it just Florida has this,
well,
what's crazy is Florida has its own Medicare fraud phone number.
Why every other state calls one number.
That's some shit.
It's hilarious man.
It is.
Oh my God.
What a wacky ass fucking state.
So what he was telling me last night,
we were talking about the uh,
Oxycontin Express,
that documentary about all the people that were getting these uh,
oxycontin prescriptions from those pain management centers.
And he said that they had replaced,
it was a boxing and they just start telling me,
cause he told me was a drug counselor.
I was like,
oh,
I need to fucking hear what's going on down there.
And I didn't expect a can of worms that you opened up.
I was like,
what?
I can't,
how much,
how much money is going on through what?
And that's just Florida.
That's just Florida to what happens in Massachusetts or California or something
like that.
Like they're different.
I haven't done therapy there.
But what's funny is all of the patients that wind up at the willow or on the
rounds,
so they come from California,
they come from Boston,
they come from all these places and they're,
the willow is just around to do,
they have a timeframe where they have to get out by,
and it depends.
Different plans.
So they have like 90 lifetime days that um,
every year rebirth.
And then you have 160 days during the year so you can go in 30 days,
come out 30,
wait 30 it repopulates again.
Now the patients though that people that use this,
they know the systems better than the doctors do better than the insurance
specialists and everything.
The place I was at actually has a salesforce upfront.
They call the people that come through their alumni and frequent fliers and so
they will call him and go,
hey,
it's been awhile since you've been in who?
Whoever,
um,
why don't you come in for a medication adjustment?
Wow.
It's illegal as fuck.
And they call them in for medication adjustment.
And so who's instigating that?
Is it the employees?
Is there a director that tells the employees what they have to do?
Like how does that work?
They keep it really,
really close.
So there's two or three friends that are close with the owners that work in the,
well,
it's not sales department,
it's the admissions department,
but we all know it as the sales department.
It's like an Audi dealership.
The undercoating that's like Fargo.
You want to get that undercoat got 50 thousands of bucks in points,
but they won't call you to Vegas unless they know you have days left.
What if you don't have days?
They can pull up your chart and go,
all right,
he's got 10 days.
He's usually here every three months.
He hasn't been back.
I wonder how he's doing.
Let's call him up.
Hey,
I know you're fighting sobriety and may have been sober for three months,
but why don't you come back for medication adjustment?
If you were really feeling sober and you would,
you would kinda like graduated past the demons of the pills and you were off of
it,
but then you got that phone call.
I got that phone call.
It's like,
look,
I got it for you.
How about a medication adjustment baby?
The dope boys have left the corner and put on white coats and moved into
psychiatric hospitals.
That's another good album.
Medication adjustment.
Yeah,
I like that.
That's a good name.
That's a good one.
Medication adjustment.
I liked that one.
You know,
thoughts and white coach.
That's amazing man.
That's amazing.
It's amazing that that's the system in place where at least in Florida,
so is that how they're making up for the money that they lost by selling all the
oxycontin's it's a pharmaceutical companies are,
they're always out to get the money.
So now there's a box in the story is pretty fucking crazy.
Uh,
in the 70s is when's the box?
And started to come out and the government was going to subsidize the payment
and anybody to build this,
please build this pill for us.
Um,
we know it works,
et Cetera.
Pfizer and all the big boys said,
fuck you.
We're not touching it.
We know it's addictive as hell.
They left it alone and a mustard company that made from us.
You see it's quite cold and
it's got people hooked on Shit.
So they were going out of business and they accepted the offer of the
government,
got paid,
took the subsidies and develop the drug suboxone problem was,
yeah,
when you were making Pfizer look good,
wow,
you're really fucking,
so that's coming from a right wing.
The problem is they had laws on the books that a physician cannot prescribe a
narcotic to get someone off a narcotic.
So then they spend the next 30 years changing the laws.
Now here comes the pill,
we're ready to market it.
Right?
So it works kind of like Methadone.
But in the marketing meeting we'd go,
look guys,
we can't rebrand methadone.
What are we going to do?
So they all sit around and they go,
well look,
everybody go in these facilities is in Aa or in a right,
so higher power stuff.
So what did they do?
The first stamp that they put on this pill as a Christian Cross and they dub it
the miracle drug.
Yes sir.
Fed it to everybody.
Hold on.
So when you get as a,
boxing has a cross,
he used to,
not anymore.
They changed it leaves.
Let me see that picture Jamie.
The little orange,
he'll find it.
Oh my God,
that is evil.
And that's some shit.
I didn't even think about that.
But Nan 12 step,
they uh,
all the alcoholics anonymous NNA they all guide based,
right?
Higher power.
Not a lot of paper.
The best acid was Jesus Christ acid.
That's what I'd heard.
Right.
Is that [inaudible] you for,
do you remember how many guys you to try the Moses Week?
But do you remember any guys came from alcoholics anonymous in a stand up
because they've learned how to stand up in front of those groups and making
everybody laugh.
Dave Fitzgerald,
remember David's Gerald died of cancer.
Yeah.
Funny fucking guy.
He was a funny guy.
Look at this.
Jesus Christ is generally,
that is,
is he literally,
yeah,
that is that a cross,
it's a sweater to crime into be both.
Is it really meant to be both?
He tried to pin it on Christians who came up with,
Oh man,
this is a Jewish thing.
It's crazy,
right?
You look at stats,
what the fuck's an eight and it's that gay rights thing.
The no hates in nature.
It's gay rights and Jesus together in harmony in heroin.
It's amazing.
I'll go with eight milligrams of the cross please.
Yeah,
it's definitely a more swordlike like cross like,
but if you were like a supercross person,
I hated Christians.
It's just a tall cross
knife.
It does a little bit.
But why that not lighting.
It's heroin addiction with heroin with a pointy thing.
I think it's tower Sabic God him surrender.
You can help people on drugs or I just said it's tower so
it's a,
that is really fucking crazy though that that's how they do it now.
They're giving it to alcoholics too,
to get them off of that.
Give you a little heroin.
You get off of alcohol.
It's hilarious in that some shit man.
It's hilarious that they were just allowed to do that and they could just decide
they're going to just give you drugs 90 days.
So why you kick a user who's only been clean 30 days.
You give him 90 days supply of suboxone and send him on his way to some other
city.
So did they have to take piss tests when they go into these rehab places?
So they might be on suboxone and who knows what the fuck they are.
They trade them,
they trade them.
We have athletes pissing into cups every two weeks.
But people who need the help.
Exactly.
Right.
Shit,
we paid $1,500 a day and we don't drug test the middle.
Right.
We drug test them when they get there just to find out all this shit they're on.
So if they give him other shit,
they don't accidentally kill him.
Wow.
That's it.
I want to know if this is all across the country.
I want to know if this is like California.
I was in Michigan course.
It's only in Florida.
[inaudible]
it's one of the craziest places ever.
So he just plays to get drugs.
Yeah,
I would agree,
right?
Yeah.
What a good state.
Now you don't even need insurance or money.
It's hard to get.
Pot is going to go to Vermont.
It's not an easy spot to get pot.
Right.
It's a little shifty.
Yeah.
You got to park and meet somebody.
Go.
Yeah.
As opposed to walking into a government run facility.
This is Elsie getting it delivered to you with your breakfast morning.
Can I speak to my Senate to plays?
You need a buzz.
I mean they're essentially giving them pills and giving them a house to live in.
Yeah,
and then transport to any city they want to go hang out with more drug addicts
and have some more fun paid for it.
That's right.
Now I understand where Nick Depaul's anger coming from.
Damn right.
That's where that Breitling rage slash snooze rage fucking.
He keeps saying that.
Joe on MSNBC,
Fox red eyes,
a good show.
They don't pay and fucking,
there's no exposure.
I quit doing it.
They don't pay.
They don't pay you at all?
Nope.
Whoa.
I used to bus gut feels balls and I was doing it.
I go,
what the fuck?
You're on a three in the morning.
It's not exactly a lot of exposure and I'm getting no money and now you want me
to research the topics but don't they have like a s scale?
They don't have none of that.
Which is funny.
I know cause I you think how successful you know,
and also it was Corey,
those shows are good because they have guys like you want,
I mean that's what makes them fun.
You know guys like you and Norton and Anthony,
right?
You opened Anthony Fan brother.
Tell him fuck yeah man.
It makes me sad that there's still split up.
I thought they would have worked the shit out by now.
Got Back together again.
Yeah.
Poor Anthony.
Hopefully they will.
I hope they will.
So you,
you stopped doing this,
you gave up your license and a,
what are you doing now?
What kind of,
you're doing more counseling now and now I can't send an allowed to say
counseling and therapy because of the license thing.
But so now you're doing like a,
you're just helping people with their lives.
Actually I do a thing that a cold,
full synergy,
right?
It's some fun language play Shit.
But for the most part,
man,
I believe in feeding the mind,
feeding the body and feeding whatever it is you believe equally on a daily,
you know,
keeping a balance,
the uh,
you know,
feeding the body relaxes the mind except that kind of stuff,
you know.
And so what I'm doing is I use my theory and instead of sitting down doing this
talk therapy,
so tell me about your fucking childhood or some shit.
Cause none of that shit really matters.
But to a point,
but a,
it's going right into helping people kind of look at what their life philosophy
is.
You know,
helping them build a more rational life philosophy to make decisions and build a
purposeful routine is what I call a purpose restructure.
Yeah.
So do you get clients from,
you get them privately now?
Like how do you,
so they have to know about you from someone else or something like that?
Yeah,
for the most part they uh,
how they find out about you,
you usually a friend of a friend or somebody that knows,
um,
I have this fucking talent of helping out the worst of the worst man.
You know,
the people that have been,
you know,
15,
20 years on heroin and you know,
hard stuff and um,
we do some out of the box treatments ever start ever since I started listening
to your show.
Oh
terms,
just an open idea to look into it myself to make those decisions.
But TDC,
TMT,
it kills mosquitoes.
Yeah.
Finished.
Sanka Sanka
my wife and I tell you last night,
just finished the uh,
little silicide and retreat if you will,
me and her at the Joshua Tree.
Did you tell the drug addicts about this?
Yeah.
You look,
let them know.
Yeah.
You could try some other stuff.
Yeah,
that would be amazing if they had a fucking mushroom place where you can go just
like they're doing with the suboxone shit.
If you had like a halfway mushroom house.
Well,
like you said,
that Shit changes your perspective sometime right.
On life.
So it might even work in it does it?
Does it,
it would work afraid of that shit.
It would work way better because you'd want to get the fuck out of that halfway
house.
That's the first thing you'd want to do.
You'd be ambitious.
It'd be like,
I got to get,
this is not what I'm,
I'm doing the wrong thing.
I got to get my life in order.
Like what am I doing here?
Accepting a government check and taking mushrooms as well.
You walk into a facility and they go bipolar.
Nicco thank you.
I can collect that check now.
Exactly.
So now you collect those.
Now you just let,
it's a very small,
you're not getting rich off of it.
I mean,
not to take any ambition away,
but if I give you a nineties a box in and you only need 30 and you sell the 60
day ago,
what are you gonna do with that money?
Uh,
you go,
so what does it as a box and like one a day and they would give him 90 for 90
days or 90 for 30 to 90 for 30 days.
Oh my God.
So they get a three a day.
So you'd just be barbecued all day long.
She's on toasted.
I'd have people sitting in my group therapy nodding,
right?
Write drooling is a box in the fuck out.
Collada pins the box in and dilauded does crazy that this is a therapy program
that you guys would be talking to.
People just jacked out of their mind out.
So maybe Brody's
on to something this whole time.
That's how I was that trashcan outside.
Oh,
that's so loud.
Maybe Bro.
It is on us.
Shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
he's been weening himself off lately,
supposedly.
What did they have him on call on him in a,
I don't know,
a ton.
I need to have the guns,
a boxing day,
and I've had heard suboxone because that's the thing.
When you said that name,
I was like,
if I heard that name from OT before,
maybe,
I don't know.
See,
I don't know enough about those fucking pills to know exactly what that means.
You know,
like,
I didn't know that Oxycontin is different than oxycodone.
It's different than Viking,
but they're all kind of similar.
Right.
After all that oxycotton express stuff,
they changed the Kim,
the compounds in it,
so it become less addictive and also so you couldn't smoke it anymore.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why they changed it.
Wow.
That's amazing.
So that documentary did a world of good,
huge,
huge.
If anybody who hasn't seen that,
you've got to watch it.
But there wasn't that long ago they were running this.
If they had these pain management centers,
he'd show up with the pain management center.
Ah,
my back,
the doctor would go,
yeah,
my knees fucking drugs.
Just walk right there.
And it was another desk right there that at the drugs,
I mean like literally he was like in the same room with him and he would go
right to the pharmacist.
The pharmacist write you a little thing and give you a package and you're out
the door and you've got drugs.
One of the clients I work with,
his,
his scan that he used to do is he would get like three or four big charter
buses,
those giant ones and fill it with senior citizens from another state.
Drive him down to Florida and promise them a trip to Florida sightseeing and
lunch.
Drive him down here,
get all their scripts,
filled them all completely drive him back and keep all of their medications.
Whoa.
Yeah.
So did he get the scripts from them?
Did they have to sign the scripts over all of it so it was part of their deal.
They realized it.
They go,
yeah,
you can do this and there's that legal or is that all?
That's all ego that was hitting the pill mills.
You were just talking about Jesus Christ.
That's get a bus.
How much money could you make off of a bus of old pills?
Go to Miami figures,
60 people,
30 to 90 pills at 20 to 50 a pill.
I'm not even smiling not to be a criminal.
That just pissed me off about all this shit.
Okay.
I don't think this is,
this is one of those legal,
this isn't legal.
No,
no.
Right.
It is legal to have those pain management centers and to just,
you just walk in off the street and they're cracking down on the island.
Florida.
They're,
they're really pushing them out now because of that,
because of the documentary,
they've really shut them down,
but all they've done now is turned to psychiatric facilities.
There's three different levels of psych facilities and now Obama put out another
five.
Was it 5 million or 5 billion to open up more because there's a need for said
Obama.
He said the o word for nick.
The shit,
the government ain't coming from my side of the fucking sounds good cause it's
wrapped in the shroud of we're helping more mental health facilities.
I always wrap the boy shit a shit.
Exactly.
It's a good,
it's a convincing argument against big government for sure.
It's a convincing argument that people,
when you give them the opportunity to make a shitload of money by controlling a
segment
of anything,
whether it's,
you know,
whatever it is,
mental health,
anything.
As soon as they figured out there's a spot where they could start extracting
money.
They just do take your ambition away and make you,
that's you.
You focus on that a lot,
right.
And it's totally true.
I mean,
at anybody says it's not the idea that you,
you become reliant violate you violate human nature.
Human nature is if someone has to scratch and scrounge,
you get ambitious.
You figure your way out of a hole.
That's what most people do.
And you know,
a lot of the,
you know,
the people that I've seen in these hospitals,
you see a glimmer of hope that want to do that,
but then they're hit by the same phrase,
I get way fucking tired of hearing.
It's not your fault.
You don't have a disease.
Geez us a golf fuckers.
That's like a blanket statement for the times we live in.
When you get nowhere,
nobody's responsible for anything are accountable for any that happened in the
70s too.
And Mr. Carl Rogers came out with positive psychology.
When we sit in front of you and tell you how great you are at everything despite
how shitty you are at everything.
And so as we start to tell you you're great at everything,
now we can go,
well,
it's not a disease.
It's all right.
It's a disease.
I mean it's not your fault.
So you know,
just BNA the rest of your life do nothing.
Um,
when you agree,
sorry to interrupt you,
but it is kind of a disease to a point.
What they're really trying to say is that after a long time of doing it,
we don't know what's up with your brain.
And you know you had Carl Hart,
Dr Karl Horn on here,
a huge follower of him.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
When he did,
you had it on here.
The brain scans,
everyone's seen the famous brain scan of methamphetamine and not this person's
on Meth,
this person's not.
And you see the dark blue part and the light up part of the brain.
What they don't tell you is that's normal differentiation.
If all of us took a brain map right now,
it would all be different.
And the difference between the person on math and not all meth is within normal
range.
It means fucking nothing really.
It means absolutely nothing.
Whoa.
So people just sort of acclimate to it.
They see a picture,
you know,
it's Mcdonald's.
I wanted to,
yeah,
that,
that's it.
Oh,
hilarious.
And he would say it means absolutely nothing.
It's all normal differentiation.
Wow.
So it varies throughout the day.
It varies based on what you're doing.
Yeah.
Wow.
I remember,
uh,
he says that 85% of the people using methamphetamine have never been to rehab,
never been on disability and work.
Yeah.
He was very illuminating.
A lot of things to do was saying about what would it actually feels like to get
off of a drug.
It's like everybody makes it out.
Like it's this horrible thing that withdrawal.
He was like,
it's like having the flu.
It seems like.
It's like you feel shitty for a little while.
Alcohol and Benzos,
benzodiazepines are truly the only two drugs you can die.
Detoxing from.
Alcohol is the worst.
It affects every cell,
every organ in your body at once.
Isn't that we took out Amy Winehouse.
I think that's what took her out.
I think.
Uh,
she got off of alcohol withdrawal symptoms just whacked around.
Not Crazy fucking alcohol did around.
So how can you fix this thing?
How can this thing be fixed?
Oh,
she's done.
She's done nothing.
The first thing is decriminalization period.
I mean you,
you don't lock somebody up when they just need help trying to get their life
together and a drugs are a fucking symptom.
Stop treating the symptom.
I mean we got people all cooped up telling them they got fucking personal
defects,
whatever the fuck that means.
And then sitting them in a circle and go a few of those.
No,
no.
But your higher power made you perfect.
Oh okay.
I was trying to get better but not anymore.
We can just,
we can just start a Kickstarter and tried to get a border around Florida.
I'd give it to like Puerto Rico or something.
At what point do you get offended when someone has a Kickstarter?
Do you get offended when someone likes you?
We want to kickstart like a tour or kickstart,
like a tee shirt line or like starting like,
hey,
pay my rent.
People like,
that's a lot.
Like I like,
like I saw kickstarted him and Stimpy,
I forget his name.
Uh,
very popular artists and he wants to do a new cartoon.
I,
you know,
it's that kind of stuff.
I'm mad like creating something that isn't he rich enough or ready now.
I don't know if you've kept up money.
Might have been doing blow.
Yeah.
I get sick kids.
That's the one I always see.
Yeah,
there's a lot of that one,
hey,
my kid's sick.
Those go fund me ones.
The problem with it was like somebody will tweet them,
would you please retweet this?
You know,
like,
I definitely want to,
if it's real.
Right.
I definitely don't want to it's face.
Exactly.
So you don't,
it's hard to tell until you got to do a little fishing around before you or you
just kind of say,
well,
and then it's just too much work because I have to research and see if this kid
even exists.
I think the x Ray,
the kid's liver and yeah,
I need a blood sample.
If you're in Florida,
they would give you the right school and urine male that kids love to me,
Fedex,
that pissed me tomorrow and I'll send you six bucks.
It's nice that people do that though.
Like when something legitimately does come up and someone can help somebody.
I think it's cool.
I think it's one of the cooler things about the internet that we have that and
that's ultimately what charity really should be,
right?
It shouldn't be like something that the government provides the people each
other.
Right.
I need for the government essentially to,
we have so many hands in the pot.
I mean,
if we were all on an island and we all got some sort of virus,
we got to finish the,
the whole,
um,
uh,
antibacteria right?
We gotta,
we gotta finish the antibiotic,
right?
To be able to cure it with what we're doing in the United States is going,
here's 10.
Oh Shit,
here's 10 problems out of these 10 problems.
All of you get one antibiotic.
There you go.
And then we'll be fine.
That's what we're doing.
I mean,
you eventually got to pull everything and go,
all right,
we have to fix this first and then we'll move on.
You know,
one person or one field or one group of people has to finish the antibiotic to
help out with the virus before we're just passing out to everybody.
Did you ever feel while you were working there that you were engaged and like a
system that will never be fixed?
Fuck yeah.
I mean,
you must feel like they broke me,
man.
I,
no shit.
It broke me man.
I was,
I walked in,
uh,
you know,
ready,
like I said,
ready to help the world and do what I can.
And by the time I had to leave,
you know,
kind of asked me to leave,
uh,
after about a year or so,
I was just like,
what the fuck?
You know,
I started feeling bad for the patients that are caught up in it.
Cause now you're hooked on it so much.
You believe it.
I mean,
and a lot of people just doing what the white coat tells him.
I mean that's,
that's how it kind of,
we're taught,
you know,
so you trust your doctor,
but the days of trust in your doctor these days,
unless you find really good ones is fucking dead man.
Yeah.
I mean,
I got parents that call me that are friends of mine and they're talking to me
about putting,
you know,
they're your kids on these drugs or this drug.
And he's like a six year old who's just an awesome fucking kid.
He's just running around like a bad ass,
you know,
doing kid shit.
Get the little boys in Redland maximum minutes.
I tried to convince this person nothing's wrong with their own child.
Yeah.
Oh,
something's wrong.
Oh Kay,
look.
So I'm like,
Oh yeah,
look,
he's five and he's awesome.
Well,
when they tell you that a kid can't pay attention school,
so you've got to put them on Adderall.
I was talking to my friend Justin about this just yesterday.
Couldn't pay attention in school.
So they're putting them on Adderall.
I go to school is boring as fuck,
especially for a kid.
And he's a wild little kick,
wild,
energetic kids that tell you that she,
they put him on with you.
They put them on methamphetamine.
Methamphetamine.
Yeah.
I mean that's what it is,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it's like,
what is it a cloak,
close cousin to mess that methamphetamine.
It was just one additional molecule that that changes the constant of makeup.
But it's basically the same thing.
So does it have the same effect on impulse control?
Cause isn't that like a big thing with meth?
Like they start doing like really dumb shit.
Well people that may have ADHD or whatever that is,
um,
they may have it if,
say they drink caffeine or they do something like,
um,
Adderall or a stimulant,
it causes focus.
And so you get focused.
And if somebody that doesn't have attention problems there Sedro drinks your
coffee,
you get hyped,
you get moving,
you can't stay still.
Right.
So it does the opposite.
Somebody who was good add,
if they drink caffeine,
they tend to focus more.
That's right.
So that makes,
and I've heard that people that have add that drink coffee,
sometimes they'll go to sleepy.
That's right.
Yeah.
To me,
100 Brian,
I can drink coffee at two in the morning and fall asleep.
But isn't that also a tolerance?
You can drink a lot of coughing cause you'd drink a lot of caffeinated
beverages.
True.
And now that these cold press coffee everyone has,
these are days cold price,
third,
like 10 times the amount of caffeine.
Then like regular ice coffee does this 10 times more than the ice coffee from
Starbucks and ice coffee from Starbucks is 10 times more than like a hot coffee
from Starbucks or something.
Crazy amount.
So cold brew has more caffeine.
Oh yeah.
Tom Do you to try one of those,
uh,
open up that a fridgerator and get one of those caveman nitros.
Hey,
can't even keep them in stock.
I to give you a little too amped up.
We'd go to the gym with those I tear muscles.
Yeah,
I started taking it right.
There's some things you may not know about your own Alpha brain and new moon.
Man.
I wanted to tell you,
but do you want to tell me one?
It's a fucking love it and it changed my life,
but I don't want to put it out there.
And people may think that it really does what I'm going to say it does,
but it's what it did for me.
Okay.
Uh,
literally,
well that's good to hear.
Quit smoking cigarettes because of that.
How's that?
I don't fucking know.
I don't think you could.
I think you can quit smoking cigarettes cause he didn't want to smoke
cigarettes.
I mean,
I think to a point,
what Alpha brain does is it helps your memory,
helps a,
what they call executive function even helps reaction time.
There's all
sorts of things that been proven that all the ingredients in that stuff do,
but you and new movie.
But you will,
those are good things.
They're both,
well,
I had a doctor,
Rhonda Patrick on the podcast yesterday and she was,
she's amazing.
And she was talking about addiction and she was talking about,
uh,
people with impulse control issues and related that to serotonin deficiencies
and five HTP and l Tryptofan,
which is what new moods made out of which converts to Serotonin and your body.
And how important that is to maximize that,
to keep you like literally your impulse control and addictions and things like
that can be affected by those chemicals that are in your brain and you can
supplement those,
those chemicals and literally changed like the way you behave.
It's fucking bizarre stuff naturally without naturally without drugs.
That's right.
Yeah,
and no withdrawal symptoms.
If you don't take Alpha brain just didn't dig it.
It doesn't do anything to,
same thing with just regular five HTP.
Two you can get at any store for just regular five HTP that can get at any
vitamin store will absolutely enhance your brain's production of Serotonin.
That so much so that they tell people that are on Ssri is to not take it because
we'd taken that stuff.
You could get like Serotonin Syndrome.
We you have too much serotonin.
Want that?
Please let me have that.
I ate mushrooms twice in Toronto this last week and Shit Friday and Saturday
night,
but the second day I don't have mushrooms.
Takes your serotonin and all,
but Saturday I was so sad.
I was crying at everything.
I was just in my hotel room crying and I've never heard that before.
It does.
It sure wasn't the hotel don't do that.
But all you gotta do is pop to new mood after that and your grave.
Yeah.
So it's just the,
the,
your levels get depleted from buy mushrooms.
I didn't never heard of mushrooms because that's what somebody else told me
cause I add the second night I was just a mess.
Maybe it's just the two nights in a row.
You just wrecked it.
Yeah.
Do you still off the cigarettes?
Uh,
I kind of cheated in Toronto,
so it was hard.
You're on mushrooms and everyone's smoking and I went to this bar.
This is how it is now.
I went to,
this bar is awesome.
It's called the bill Hicks Bar and this guy owns a bar called the bill Hicks
Bart.
And it's this really small bar and you walk in and it's the most amazing little
hole in the wall.
Bar Drinks are super cheap and he's just a huge hit span and he's like the
nicest owner ever.
What a great game.
I highly recommend his talk Bill Hicks.
Where is it?
It's right down the street from the comedy underground from the Louie Louie
Anderson.
Nick,
take care.
You got to see him cause when he came through Boston done.
Yeah,
I got to see Hicks when I went to move to New York.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He actually came up to me and said he'd like one of my bits girls having dirty
tits assault
dude.
Yeah,
I remember that Beth and I was like,
oh my God.
It was like Ted Williams just told me I could hit a baseball and I was like,
yeah.
Even when he was like in his thirties he was just such a strange guy
buddy.
He was like a mystical guy.
Like even before,
you know,
he died really young.
He was only like 32
you have 33 when he died,
the bill Hicks bar drinks to walk in and he's watching like flashed on the team
is really small TV and has all these records.
Ha Ha hanging up.
Did it just start?
It says this shit's open
July 13th is that what it said on the team?
It's been open for awhile.
Um hmm.
But yeah,
he closed the bar just for us and everyone from the show came over and we just
drank all night.
God Damn Party in Toronto.
Like look at you hanging out with Dean del Rey Party and Rockstar style,
any height.
And He's sitting there eating candy and just say it's bags of candies.
Like Brian,
check this out.
And like all these different Twizzlers where I'm showrooming idea he doesn't do
anything right.
He doesn't do anything.
He's been sober for 20 some years.
Meanwhile he's wrecking his body by eating candy.
Oh I,
that's what I was telling him.
He cause he,
he's like,
I quit caffeine.
I'm like,
yeah,
but you just ate seven snickers bars and you have 20 gummy bears in your hands.
Like horrible health habits.
And so talking about how they quit doing,
one of them quit caffeine.
He was telling me the other day that it,
oh yeah,
my memory's better.
Everything's better.
Quit that caffeine man.
I've done quit caffeine.
Yeah.
$8,000 worth of barbecue.
You know,
the next day barbecue is not bad for those.
Bad for you is sugar.
Yeah.
Sugar is fucking bad,
man.
That was one thing that Rhonda was covering yesterday.
Like the effect of inflammation,
sugar when you eat and what it does to your gut health.
Poisoned.
Especially as we get the Brh nick the following it a little bit older lover
sugar guy though.
No,
no.
I'm less of a shit show.
It's like get all the though.
I'm going the other way.
I'm starting to like ice cream and she and I never liked ice cream and cookies,
but they say that about old p.
That's right.
My,
it's my old man.
That's all each night
it's cause you got to taste it.
I know that's right.
That's right to self when I'm older.
So just the leave the sugar alone.
Yeah.
It's just if you can't help it,
it's all you can taste.
One of the big bit about it.
That's what I eat girls' butts now because I can taste what do they shit and
cotton candy anymore many years of seasoning.
That's what I'm eating.
And when I think of sugar treats,
that's a,
that's how Brian thinks he's got a very linear path.
He doesn't question it.
Not as good as proteins upfront.
What does that shirt you wearing?
A David show.
Oh,
it's one of his art pieces.
Oh Wow.
David Cho wore my special shirt today to
[inaudible] with a gun.
That's a chapel.
That was his middle school picture.
Yeah,
that's right.
No,
it's a,
I stole it from a friend a d,
but um,
it's a shirt trying to get awareness that if you know the drug problem,
what they're doing,
the cartels are over there.
This is how the kids are coming up and it's just kind of doing awareness.
Do we?
Oh,
good.
I don't know how they did it,
but they made it happen.
He's got a big hand.
It's got a little chick fucking hog on them.
Yeah.
I see.
I got approached by three Mexicans in the parking lot when I was assured that I
thought they were going to,
and they liked it.
No,
no,
they,
they're mad at you.
Right.
Who said that?
Mexican explained it and they were like,
oh,
that's good it,
nevermind.
That's good.
Let's go to it.
You know?
But it's offensive at the first look.
Like most people
they look at and go,
Oh shit,
I'm offended right away.
Naturally for that.
Would you please?
Yeah,
they do.
The drug thing is called Shane.
Make them less shame.
Shame.
Little game of Thrones action.
Do you watch game of Thrones?
Nicole?
How dare you.
Oh,
Tashi is Gerald's hilarious.
I brought it up to her.
She goes,
I don't like those shows that are just make them ups.
I can
suspend my disbelief.
I can't even watch real movies where a fucking I'm watching you Angelina Jolie
beat up six fucking mail may be seals.
I'm sorry I can't get this.
Listen,
if you know good moves and you know the heels are strong,
they could take your,
uh,
that's the best stilettos stilettos.
Ronda Rousey probably kick a lot of dude's ass going to say that to you.
I'm watching.
This is where political correct is always has to go one step too far.
I'm watching Bryant Gumbel and his stupid fucking real sports and he has to,
they have to make the comp.
The guy goes,
Ronda Rousey,
uh,
is the pound for pound,
both male or female best mixed martial arts fighter on the,
well,
Gee,
let's find that out.
Is it an easy way to find that out?
There's no way to find that out.
The reality about that,
it's totally subjective in his opinion.
She can be the best pound for pound fighter in the world,
but you can never prove that.
That's all just completely speculation,
but,
well,
you put her against no guy.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't her experience and her weight.
Mayweather and then you find out.
Yeah,
just like they did in the seventies remember wide world of Sports Guy,
I think you got do pound for pound.
You've got to separate the genders.
This is why,
but they didn't in the premise gel.
It's my point.
See the premise.
It's a fake premise and that's what I'm saying,
but it's a politically correct.
You're right,
you're right.
It's a fake.
Nobody calls people on this bullshit.
I'm fucking sitting there yelling at the TV.
Well,
okay.
And both male,
female.
She's the best.
Well,
let's talk and find out who was calling somebody on some bull shit last night on
stage.
Man.
You were killing it last night and calling that shit out.
I'm not giving away any bits or anything.
Thank you very much.
You're ripping somebody up Joe.
No,
it's just fun.
It was awesome.
Some people do it is all I'm saying.
Some people call out bullshit and yeah,
just,
Oh,
Joe goes,
um,
that's,
I did not know that.
This is fucking weird man.
What a weird,
weird time we're in right now.
You know,
this just seems like there's more wackiness going on right now in the world and
anytime that I could ever remember does seem like more,
more hypocrisy,
more contradiction,
more chaos.
Oh fuck.
Oh yeah.
We've got to get through this shit right before it gets better.
I'm guessing.
I don't know.
Does it get worse before it gets better when the language starts,
when words don't mean anything by that,
that's when the,
that's a sign of the times when languages me anymore.
Like,
what do you mean?
Well,
political correctness.
Oh Shit.
It just doesn't mean anything anymore.
I see people,
I saw people yesterday on the news out here somewhere protesting.
They were upset because their restrictions at too much on sex offenders.
Oh my God,
that's fucking finished.
Yeah,
real someone was before I made
a movie making fun of a fucking,
I couldn't believe what I was watching.
It's like a parody of the sex offender one is a fucked up one because there's
evidence that shows that when you molest a child that child is more likely your
you could damage them so fucked up.
They're more likely to molest somebody else.
Like you can literally infect them with this sickness that you have.
Most people that are molesters have been molested hubs.
How fucking crazy as that.
I mean it's just the gift that keeps on giving.
Just the horrible,
horrible,
horrible disease.
I mean that's like a disease.
It's like a disease of the psyche,
like a herpes of the psyche.
Like more worse,
like an aids of the psyche,
you know,
dairy.
Can you imagine running that study?
Well,
it certainly,
it certainly is a choice to decide whether or not to do exactly the same thing
that happened to you.
But the desire to do it is what's fucked up.
Like the idea,
like to everyone in this room,
I just assume I like you guys.
I assume none of you wanna fuck kids,
right?
No,
but I've seen,
I've seen a girl at the rage and I'm like,
Holy Shit that these events and make made the decision not to fucking try to
move on.
But that's different.
That's what ain't 17 and 18.
And one of the reasons why it's different with an eyepatch
dairy.
Do you think,
do you think there's less molesters now because since porn has become so,
uh,
available and more available to people that you think there's more,
less molesters?
That's a good argument.
You know,
there's arguments for that.
The one of the arguments is that if you give people a release like video games
or like watching even like really offensive or violent porn,
that you release that tension inside of them.
And the other argument is that it stimulates their fantasy and we want to go out
and make it reality.
I don't know which one's right.
I don't need,
I think the problem is it's both.
I think with some people it's going to stimulate their fantasies and they're
gonna want to go out and actually do that.
And with other people it's going to satiate their evil tendencies.
Some people that were molested,
they think that's what you're supposed to do.
Like,
do you know somebody,
you know,
like shit,
I was beat as a kid,
you know,
coming up a few,
it was violent enough and so early in my,
in my life I thought that that's what you do.
Somebody says,
no,
doesn't do shit.
You,
you heard him or you heard something,
you know,
and so you just kind of register that this is what happens and this is what you
do.
And so a lot of people,
they were,
you know,
I had a,
I don't know,
I want to tell us our client's stories.
That all right.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Just don't say any names.
Yeah.
She,
she was molested for eight years by her brother and underneath out in the barn
where the dad used to work on the car.
They had dug a hole and they would work underneath the car.
So the brother would take her in the middle of the night and do that.
Then dad finds out eight years and then he joins in for the next 10 she is,
yeah,
and counsel.
That shit.
Why Council?
Yeah.
Look at them and say,
it's not your fault.
You have a disease now.
You're fine.
Go home.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Get to that can't and you can never get a regular life back.
It's like that girl's life is so scarred with those images and memories.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
but that's what she has do.
So she goes and would begin to put herself in situations to be raped.
Oh God.
Because that's the comfort zone.
That's what they're,
that's where they're supposed to be there.
Oh my God.
Now someone could possibly protest against stiff sentences to that.
That's insane.
That's insane that people were protesting,
that they're,
they're developing communities now.
They're starting to move in one section of cities and gathering total cities
like that through like websites or something like that.
Change moving to certain areas,
man.
And guess what?
It's in Florida.
Florida was weird when I was like 18 man first came out.
I go to,
is there any episodes?
Not from fucking floor.
It was asking that years ago and now like comics is a ton of comics who do that
premise now,
but I was like every episode's from what the Fuck's going on in Ocala?
I just left.
I've been living on Marco Island and Naples down or mark eyeline is,
yeah,
I left there.
You could probably change the southwest Florida tag line to come be as racist as
you want to be.
You know what I mean?
You could.
It's crazy.
I mean in gated communities there are hanging the old word open the front.
I mean they're doing shit
word out in Florida that I'd never heard before.
He cheese the how's that you ever heard of Geechees last damn g cheese is a
derogatory term for African Americans.
That's the first for me.
Hmm.
No.
And I'm from Oak Coy.
So dude,
a dude lived in West Palm told me that they were all they were.
They were saying that when they grew up,
they were all,
I'm using the word Geechee like to describe a black people.
What does that mean?
What's a derivative?
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
it's like their version of the n word.
Wow.
That's a first for me.
Really?
They just use the n word Demec Hall at me.
Tom Sugrue and knows the story.
Matter of fact,
I think Tom's a girl was the one.
Yep.
Thompson girl was the one who told me about it.
I think Thompson Gara grew up in Florida.
I got,
I got to yell back on the,
Hey Kane on sunset the other night,
yelling like a black guy.
Oh,
did you go back to him?
Well,
it wasn't to him.
I just yelled at and I got it back,
man.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I Hate Jay back.
Whoever Jay is.
Hey Jay.
What?
Tom Segura goes this thing explaining the thing that Tom Score does.
Yells it out.
You gotta yell like a Black Guy.
It Shit.
I could try to do.
It was like,
oh,
hold on.
Oh,
okay.
Then I need to do it bikes.
He has this thing where like if you go around a bunch of black people that yell
like a black guy,
like yell something out,
someone will like yell back to layer.
This.
I heard you took,
did you take the title?
No,
I took the tile on Tom or black.
I'm,
I'm the new champion of Tom or black.
I don't know if you know what that is,
but Tom Seger on his podcast got fucking hilarious podcast with his wife.
His wife is a really funny comic.
And uh,
your mom's house,
there's their podcast.
They do this thing where it's Tom or black were Tom pretends to be black guys is
audio recordings.
It's either Tom or a black guy and you have to get,
he can really nail that.
It's pretty fun.
But I'm the chief a fucking caught them out.
Oh,
I seven out of 10.
I was correct.
Seven out of 10 that,
yeah.
Yeah.
I've got a good ear.
I've got a good ear for bullshit.
I don't know.
But he's pretty,
God damn good.
He's pretty good at it.
There was a couple that really tricked me,
but they're really hard.
It's not,
it's not the same audio quality like some of them recorded outside.
Some of them sound like an old movie,
you know him and I know him very well so it's kind of,
she was just yelling like it.
Now it's even,
it's even the yell something back at you.
Cause there was it,
there was a time when I could slang that like,
well you have that Florida accent,
which is a nice goal in summer.
You've got a little bit of urban and you're,
you're twain.
I did that.
I got an Alexa in my life.
Yeah.
Did you grow up around a lot of black people?
I did.
Did you?
There you go.
Both red,
red,
no fan.
No.
You're either redneck or ghetto.
That was it.
Where I'm from that you only get two options.
So it was it man liberal or it could be me in the middle and some days be called
wicker and then some days be called preppy.
Depends on what day it wasn't.
Who you were hanging out with.
Okay.
Florida is just so strange.
Strange,
strange fucking place.
It is man.
I went through immigration in Florida,
Atlanta from Costa Rica to Florida and the person at the counter in Costa Rica
when they were writing the,
you know the,
what is the the doc,
whatever's it is when they have to take account of everybody who's in the
airplane,
was that called?
Oh a
question.
You,
they have a form everyone on the airplane.
The docket is that it is,
yeah.
Airline docket.
I think so.
I think that's it.
Anyway,
she,
everyone's name,
Brian Red Ban.
We will need to live in and they spelled my name wrong.
So because my spelled my name wrong,
my name did not match up with the name on my passport so I had to go through
this fucking giant line.
You go into this room and you can't believe it's real.
You can't believe it's real.
I mean it's fucking insane.
There are thousands of people and if they're all going through,
because there was some sort of an error and then once you get through that you
go into another room because they know that your baggage,
if you flew from somewhere else,
you have a connecting flight.
They know your baggage is never going to fucking make it.
You pick up your bag,
it's,
you have to go through the immigration,
then you pick up your baggage,
then you have to get on another plane.
But everyone misses their plane.
I mean everyone misses their connection because the wait time,
hours and hours and hours we gave ourselves two and a half hours,
we were fucked by over an hour,
over an hour.
We were fucked.
It was insane.
And they won't take your,
your baggage within 45 minutes of the scheduled departure time.
Forget about the actual departure time cause most of the flights are delayed.
But the scheduled departure time,
they lock it down and if at 45 minutes till it gets delayed post that it doesn't
matter.
They don't open up the luggage folk you so you are stuck in this insane maze of
ropes and people are going crazy in any day of people who have to leave to take
a leak there holding it if they can.
I had my kids with me five and so on day.
They dealt with this for three
hours.
It's crazy and it's fun after awhile,
but everywhere you look,
Ebola signs,
the signs me bullet San Diego and it's hot and you're in Miami and he was
breathing and touching.
How's ins of people and I'm trying to tell my daughter,
don't put your mouth on the railing.
Don't put your mouth on this.
She's a fighter.
She's bored out of her fucking head.
They touch their face and you were trying to play games.
We're trying to joke around.
We're trying to have some fun trying to laugh about stuff,
but after a while it's five years old,
three hours and it's fucking stupid line only to get up to find out that
somebody just wrote my name down wrong.
That's what caused all that.
Yes.
It was so ridiculous.
It's so crazy.
It was like her Trent,
the card lea.
So trying to,
yeah,
there was no white people working there.
This one,
no managers like Apollo.
There was Cuban found that wasn't my,
there's Cuban people working there that literally didn't speak English like I'd
go now,
once I go to this machine,
where do I go for us?
Cup.
You'll ask costs on your board for the kiosk as it was a Casco or,
I was like,
yeah,
one time this guy literally didn't speak English in America working at the
airport.
That's I to be a racist.
That's what I'm saying.
Different thing.
Not talking about Hertz rental car.
I know it's even worse.
Do they don't speak English and Hertz rental car.
I just couldn't tell what this guy was saying.
I'm serious.
He was mumbling.
He had an accent.
I had never fucking heard of him.
He wouldn't look me in the fucking eye.
That doesn't make you racist.
Fucking yeah,
I'm the white pray you got to go to Hollywood.
Fuck you.
You fucking loss all touch.
How it's supposed to be.
Not hard to troll Nick Depaulo.
It's very,
very easy to troll the Nigga Polo
nine cups that it fucking joke off.
That helps to get you a little on the edge.
I'm getting shown fuck with that caveman coffee.
Nitro fuel.
I'm half a red bull.
You've never had a red bull.
If you want some real coffee.
I get nuts on three cups of coffee.
I can't imagine now that just looks like you are not going to drink that.
After he talked about licking buttholes,
he's not going to taste like sugar.
You're going to get anybody to drink cleanest part of a woman.
Yeah.
She's bulimic.
Anorexic
fingers to enter into their tumbler account.
People are very upset at you.
Right?
And that's being some breweries,
skinny chicks.
That's what Eddie Bravo.
He used to say the girls were on meth.
You know,
like it's,
it's better to have anal sex with girls that are on math because they don't eat.
So they never poop
that.
You know that.
It's good to say that about a constipate a girl.
Now when you're doing these,
uh,
counseling programs,
did they ever have people come in for weed?
Yes.
Actually.
What do you do?
Get them on heroin.
Yeah.
What do you,
what are you trying to do?
Said we need on the job,
they've been tested.
Okay.
So they have to come and go through it.
So I don't pay a lot attention to them anyway.
So what do you do when you,
when you say if a guy comes in and they say he's got a court,
same group,
it's all group therapy,
which is the shitty part because a group therapy modality to treat drug
addiction is awful,
but it's cheap.
I was wanting a job where I could say modality.
No,
actually sound like if I say,
you know,
I'm an asshole.
No reason ever say modality.
Clever word.
It's like the group tool or though no was perfect word.
It's just they make it fun to my own vocabulary.
But it's a bad one man.
I mean,
I mean Aa and in a,
I'm not going to front,
it has helped millions and I mean,
I'm a fan of whatever works for you.
I mean,
if some,
if someone saw us work for you,
fucking do that.
If it helps you,
you know?
So I couldn't bash anything that that helps people.
But I will point out some flaws in systems.
I mean the cult like existence of it and then you tell them to change people,
places and things.
But I need you every day to meet with the same people at the same place.
It's talking about the same things.
Yeah,
that does not do you change your life if every night I got to show up and go,
well I'm really missing that fucking needle.
I really,
and you'll see in the paint these stories and then people are around them like
yeah,
we can see,
oh man,
you know when you wrap it and that whole ritual of going and I have the stock,
I have to be like,
dude,
stop two people leave the room.
Well you're right.
They don't do that.
Jenny Craig.
They don't get up and go,
I had this cheeseburger the other night when the fucking tremendous
blue cheese I choose.
I like blue cheese,
blue cheese,
exotic come.
My goodness.
Not an ego stroke in it.
That shit man.
So I'm good point.
They go there and they talk with romantic terms about how much they used to
shoot heroin and then you give him as a boxer.
Then at the end they go,
but I'm three days clean and put the ticking the box.
That's right.
So you're not clean.
So it's a boxing like the same effect as heroin.
It's all the same.
All the same when it enters into the body.
Wow.
A lot of people,
they get that white chair right here.
The one shot.
I know a few people who took that shit wrestling.
I know that I was wanting to know this.
What is the difference between heroin and Methadone?
I know Methadone is really bad for you,
but we used to,
when I used to play pool in New York,
I used to play it an executive billiards in white plains that was down the
street from this Methadone clinic and so that we would call him the Methadone
Ian's,
they would come in and play pool and they were all like fucking completely zoned
out.
Slack charges,
play putting,
they were terrible.
There was no one,
no one ever really learned how to play.
But they would be there all the time.
They would come in there almost every day,
but they would never get good at pool.
They would just come in and zone out and bang balls around.
It's,
it's the longest treatment for heroin that's been around Methadone.
Um,
if I couldn't get into the molecules in the breakdown of it,
that's not my specialty.
But from the behavior of it,
of how people use it,
it's still daily.
I mean in a Methadone clinic will only give you up to so much.
So you go every day,
get your dose and go on about your fucking day.
Then you go back,
get your dose,
go on about fucking Nice.
Is that a substitute?
It's not physically good for him cause they control how much they give you.
So that's the only difference rail that controlling the amount and it's an
actual tactic.
Synthetics.
It's crazy because it's actually worse for you.
Is that right?
Heroin.
Is Heroin Natural?
Well not really
excluding it's poppy.
No Gmo,
poppy,
organic era.
I always wondered why the fuck they can't grow in the United States.
I'm like with all the greenhouses that we have,
how come they can't grow coke here?
Why didn't have to get it from Mexico?
I don't know.
I've been trying for years.
Nothing but weeds and tomatoes.
You can think about why invents a box and to begin with,
we all 80% right?
Well,
80% of the black tar heroin from Afghanistan.
if you want to fight an enemy,
where do you hurt him?
In the fucking pockets.
It's where you hit them,
right?
So when you poppy fields back in,
I dunno,
seventies eighties heroin was pretty expensive to a point and it would have its,
it would fluctuate and then suboxone is hitting all of a sudden heroin.
You can get a $10 bag of black tar heroin.
Easy.
And a lot of people go to the heroin because prescriptions are too expensive,
right?
That's what they substitutes.
So if they run out and their copay hasn't come up yet or there days having
flipped yet or they've sold all the pills,
then they just stopped by and they see the same guy.
It's the same dude on the corner.
Most of the time he's like,
what did the suboxone or the heroin and it's switch and they did a uh,
what's the box and you just have to take as a pill,
whereas heroin you have to prepare it or smoke it or do something with it.
You like to cook late at night
grilling black tar blacked out in front of my steak facing the mashed potatoes.
You see that though?
It'd be facilities man.
That's why my friend George,
he died and uh,
that's one of the things that happened before he died.
He was out playing pool with some friends of mine and he fucking pass out as
mashed potatoes.
He really did.
He fell asleep right into his food and he was,
he was a straight laced guy,
straight edge guy.
I didn't smoke cigarettes,
who's a championship pool player.
And then as he got older he hurt his back somehow.
That's how I got him on some fucking pills and he was gone.
It was gone.
I'd say half of the people in the group start out that way.
So they make us manage a group of like 15 to 22 if it's Medicare and that's the
group therapy I'm running many times,
I'm in 28 30 which is also a violation completely.
But I'd say half the people in there,
we're just normal guys.
You know,
they've got an injury or girls,
you know,
they've got an injury,
something happened,
car wreck or something,
you know,
here's a pill before you know it,
you know the divorce lost everything you know there,
you know I had some epilepsy or some seizures and then they're sitting in there
going,
I don't know what happened.
So that amazing that fast.
Those pain pills,
you know,
can,
it can take it when fucking marijuana.
It does the same thing.
But does it though?
I don't know if it does matter.
I mean I've had a,
I had a morphine drip more feed one of those more.
I enjoy the morphine.
I had my shoulder.
Oh wait,
what do you have doing new shoulders?
Oh,
like him in high school.
Did you ever get lucky?
I had reconstructive on both.
I'm trying to avoid one.
I've got a labor him tear on this one,
but I got a stem shell shock the other day.
I don't know if it's going to work,
if it doesn't work,
I'm going under the knife.
But I woke up from one of the surgeries,
I'm morphine and I,
uh,
and I,
I got operated on a Christmas Eve,
this sounds like a senior in high school or whatever.
And it was a big,
a styrofoam candy cane like in the room.
And I hit the nurse over the head with it.
Fuck.
Did you know what you're doing?
No,
I was on fucking,
Murphy was drank in high school.
I didn't fucking do drugs.
I'll send them on ma.
I don't know if I can get out of my room.
Did it fix your shoulders?
Can you say football and college have to both operations.
I had a guy named Lyle,
I still remember his name.
Wow.
And uh,
I went to a doctor because they had a little bit of a tear or a few years ago.
I mentioned my doctor's name,
this is back in the 80s.
And he goes,
I just went to a Harvard to listen to him speak.
You got to work on my shoulders.
She had a tear recently that was like,
I had a slight tear like five s five years ago.
And so that is,
they don't have to operate on a no,
it was nothing.
But I messed him up when I was younger I would fog and I dislocated them each
about 30 times and I separated.
This guy did 30 of these operations,
30 to 40 a year.
He'd been doing it for 20 years that he's,
he did my first one,
he goes,
that's the worst shoulder of a scene than he did my second one.
Cause that was worse than your first one.
Wow.
We get back in the 80s were lifted.
We wouldn't stretch trying to bench 300 pounds,
you know what I mean?
Just stupid shit.
And then when I got hit and football was really the weights that fucked me up
and up and play ball for a little while.
You helped me a lot when I was an open miker without even knowing it because I
saw you on stage and I said,
this guy does not look like a fucking comedian.
He looks like a big football player looking handsome bastard.
Funny.
But I was like,
people hate you for that because we live in this business is neuro Advil.
They fucking,
this is their turf.
Well they,
it Mark Marin literally said like he was joking around about it but he said he
really felt like this is not for you guys.
Yeah.
Cool guys.
Well I thought I was,
I know and then I saw it because I was an open mic,
but I saw you.
I go,
oh,
okay.
He can do it.
If he can do it,
he's better looking than me.
He's bigger and handsomer like I'm all right.
I'll sneak in.
Nick Dipaolo is working and phonies.
I have a clip for me like literally my second year in the business doing it like
an eight minutes set.
The comedy connection and I have a suit jacket on it and it fits me like Shannon
Sharpe was,
is like on CBS fit like a teacher and it looked so stupid.
I get that greasy Italian mullet.
I even hate it.
People hated me.
You were a big thick dude,
played up at Maine and it was a fucking lifting weights every day and you could
tell the nerves to fucking,
they want,
they just don't.
That's what kills me about people like this in this business.
They hate people who are intolerant yet they've fucking lucky.
We go,
ugh.
You know this guy's,
it was automatically like to assume that you're one of those intolerant.
Beat
him up.
Yeah.
No,
I get along with everybody.
Nerd's gotta fucking guys or did drugs and yeah,
so did I.
I knew a lot of guys that did drugs and I knew a lot of nerves.
I knew a lot of guys who did drugs and that's what kept me from doing drugs and
I was in high school.
That's right.
I had my friend Jimmy's got an older cousin and we had some mutual friends in
his mutual friends.
There were three or four years older than me,
so when I was like 14 and 15 these guys were fucking hitting the wall.
They were getting out of high school and just losing their fucking minds and
selling drugs and fallen apart and losing weight and getting addicted.
I was watching guys la spiral out of control and I was like,
fuck coke.
Sometimes that's the best way to show somebody that.
Yeah,
it sucks is somebody has to be your sacrificial goat.
You have to watch somebody fall apart at the altar.
True.
Well,
that's like a,
it's a classic.
It's a classic way that people learn by watching other people fuck up and when
you take away the possibility people fucking up,
then you get into some weird state that you've got in these clinics where it's
like you're not really fucking up so you're not really hitting rock bottom.
So the other people don't even see you as doing that bad.
No know there's Nikki stays in the house.
That's the new normal.
Yeah,
they gave me the moccasins.
Good.
I got a good place with suboxone.
They have these Rehab Romances that happen all the time.
It's,
it's a thing they,
they're,
they're in there,
you know,
cause I think people connect in fear more than they do love.
So two people will meet and they'll go like,
how dare you?
Well what's your disability check?
What's my disability check?
And they go like,
you know what,
I love you.
We can do this together.
Fuck yeah.
And then they go out and it doesn't mean that to nail Polish.
That's my girl.
Well you'd see him,
they all had the bands on,
cause they get bands from the meetings that they go to.
And so they were a certain everyone beads.
And so you'll see the 12 step beads all over,
tons of beating and there's,
it's arts and crafts at summer camp.
And then a week later they thought it might've got thrown up.
Some guys
fucked up,
which is weird cause I got it.
I got it.
I got notes to summer camp to where these people come back so much their hand,
things they draw and their art that they did the last hand rehab are all over
the wall and shit.
And so they're coming back like it was
serious.
They draw their hands and they're,
they're affirmations,
you know.
Oh five affirmations.
Oh it wasn't,
they have diseases.
It's a disease.
Nick Depaulo.
Oh Jesus.
Don't do a joke.
But it's kind of a disease right now being addicted.
No,
he says no.
Nope.
No room for discretion.
As well.
I loved the discussion.
A discussion.
I've fucking disgusted in a facility though.
Let me,
let me get rid of the word disease.
Cause I think disease like a lot of other words.
There's a lot of weight behind it.
Right?
General though.
So let's,
let's just say instead of let's set up instead of a disease,
when a person becomes addicted to something,
there's obviously a physical issue.
So we'll call it a disease,
call it an ailment,
cause it call it something.
When someone gets addictive behavior,
it's definitely behavior that locked it in.
But once you get addicted and you're just trapped in the clutches of a drug,
what is that?
If it's not a disease,
for me it's behavioral.
For me it's all behavioral to the idea that they're using is a symptom.
The drugs themselves,
it's a symptom of something else.
I would tell you that eight out of the 10 people that are sitting in my,
you know,
group therapy,
when I,
when I was doing it had been a child abused.
You know,
I've been through some serious shit,
you know,
and so most of it,
it comes from that.
Now the drugs they put on top of it,
if it's,
if you only council,
hey,
you're so focused on this drug,
it becomes the drug is the problem and you ignore the shit that the person's
going through.
Been through the fact that I don't know whatever's happened to them.
And so we'd rather beat them up about their inability to make a choice not to do
a drug.
Then really work out of what's the drug give you?
What are you getting by using the drug and you know,
can you,
can you teach how to use the drug better?
Can you,
and you know,
swap drugs even,
I mean it just get pimped out by the system essentially.
100% man,
100% in bipolar.
This dike fucking diagnosis that drives me absolutely insane.
Now there's a DSM four,
you know,
the Dsm five is driving saying,
cause everybody thinks they have it and it's really,
really rare.
It's a rare diagnosis.
I think.
I got it.
That's what people do feel like I've got an ex girlfriend or some shit.
Maybe bipolar.
No,
no,
no.
When you're a kid,
five HTP.
When I first met you,
you said you had like a testosterone and over amount.
When you said you were like,
when I first met you.
Oh you only,
I was like fucking risk meant me.
Yeah,
no,
I was still fighting.
Yeah,
I was at,
I mean that was just out of my mind that a fear,
I'm sure there's no use buying set.
When you were younger as a kid,
you always had like hyper energy and shit when you grow up with violence.
I grew up with domestic violence.
When you grow up with that,
your program to respond and react quickly,
you know,
told me about this vigilance.
Hypervigilance.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's a lot of studies being done on kids who grew up in violent households
and um,
uh,
when they become football players or pro football players and involved in a
domestic violence or fighters as well,
they developed this hair trigger reaction to things overreact,
make like mistakes that they can't rebound from.
And a lot of it is because they think of the,
the actual programming that occurs when they're in the womb,
even when their mother is experiencing violence from your father,
right.
Literally changes their genes in the womb.
It does.
They actually come out and fearful of the father's voice.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Michael Irvin told me this.
I was on a plane flight with him just randomly and luckily he's the nicest
fucking guy in the world.
He's such a nice guy.
And uh,
we were flying Australia together.
This is a long ass flights.
We had a long conversation because you know they have that little area in the
middle where the bathroom is,
you could stand up,
stretch your legs.
Yeah.
Him and I are just talking about football and about the work that he's been
doing with young kids that grow up around violence.
So that was,
you know,
I'd grown up around that.
Then I'd competed in martial arts tournaments from the time I was 15 to 21 zero
was when you met me.
I was very crazy.
I was like from 21 till I did,
it took me a long time to relax.
You know,
I feel the same job.
I don't know what your,
you know,
your family life was like,
but mine was violent every day.
Man,
day in and day out.
And I played football myself.
I used to be two 45 is a lot bigger than this.
And um,
you know,
I had that hair trigger.
That was the reaction and that's why I went into football.
And what I like to talk to people about is,
I mean,
it's a war zone.
When your home is really like that in your a child,
there's no difference than going to Afghanistan.
It's horrible.
And a soldier going through was dramatic row,
right?
Post traumatic stress.
And then a three year old that every day is watching,
you know,
his father choke his mom to sleep right across the room or put guns in their own
mouths.
But I mine mine sounds a lot less than yours.
And I got out when I was five and then my mom remarried the nicest guys like a
hippie.
So changed as completely all violence,
but all violence was gone.
So then I had to reintroduce it into my life by fighting football was that
outlet for me.
I got an adopted 15 year old daughter.
So when you hear about the Stepdad,
you know,
when you say that you know her,
her dad's a piece of shit,
he's out of the picture and has been since she was five.
So for about 10 years she's mine.
And,
um,
we,
I think we came in just in time,
you know,
to where none of that's around,
but the violence does so much for the influencing what,
what children do and become and how they react.
I mean,
if you go back to those,
the primal error,
you know,
when we had to react,
it was life or death,
fight or flight.
You,
you implement that into a three year old who literally are seven or five,
who's literally worried about the big monster named daddy who's going to cut on
the hall light and come in the room.
Yeah.
I mean,
this is a fucking giant to these tiny,
right.
And you know,
it had that.
And then think about that woman who was molested by her brother and her father.
Fuck,
that's right.
And you're going to say,
what?
Come here for 30 days and let's talk about it and good luck.
I mean that,
that's it.
That's what we fucking offer them.
Just here's more drugs.
God dammit.
You know,
I've had some clients where I wanted to be like,
you don't want to just keep doing fucking trucks,
man.
It's not going to get any better.
You're having more fun this way,
you know,
just control it.
Try not to kill yourself.
Do you remember back then Nick were like 2122 years old.
Like,
do you remember how like hair trigger you were as a young man?
Do you do,
do you really take into consideration the amount of mellowing you've done over
time,
especially you and you like football guys in particular,
that is a fucking explosive sport.
You are just,
you know,
we think about what a regular kid does during the day or regular kid does.
It doesn't play sport like that.
And then what you're doing,
you're involved at fucking collusions giant dudes.
Me Think about what you did to your shoulders,
all that kind of crazy chaos and violence becomes a part of your normal everyday
world
to mention your testosterone level was growing up and throw Bose on that at a
party.
I,
my first girlfriend broke up with me because I get a couple of fights,
you know,
parties and um,
but what else do you do with it?
I mean your bread to be a fucking warrior from day one saying it's a healthy
outlet to play football and stuff.
At that point,
you can get a lot of trouble if you don't know what I mean.
I know guys who didn't play that.
We're fucking pretty violent.
At least I was taking it out on people in practice.
Well,
I think there's definitely something to be said for finding an outlet for
violence,
like an aggressive lit for aggressive action and something that calms your body
down.
Especially for young men.
I don't you mean football's a tricky one because there's the fucking studies
that are coming back now on football fan anymore,
man,
I don't what the fuck.
I was a huge football fan,
watched it all the time,
played it in.
The more research that I've been learning from,
was it amber Lyon or Rhonda Patrick that talks about the head injuries,
et cetera.
I'm like,
fuck.
The last 10 years of my life,
I'm thought there was,
he was relaying the story.
I don't remember the entire story,
but it was about a football player in college.
He gets knocked out,
he gets dinged like real bad just like,
but he's,
you know,
he's,
he's moving around,
they sit on the sidelines,
they send them back in,
he gets smashed again and now permanent damage and he's fucked at fast.
Still fucked like many,
many years later.
He's still a wreck.
I know full of four concussions,
I know of four but I also know plenty of times and I got dinged and went back
into the game.
I'm so nervous myself and I get hit by a car when I was 11 years old when he was
in the hospital for a week.
Maybe that's what made you funny.
Did you ever think about that?
Absolutely.
I'm going to end up in some article that can't be true joke cause I've been in
four total car accidents and I played semi pro football and uh,
I have my whole office about it.
Forget that John Travolta movie.
We get hit by lightening and could read people's minds because it doesn't work
the same with everybody
but does for some people they have head injuries and all of a sudden they have
new skills.
They can do math,
they can play music and dance and it doesn't work.
It can do,
it can do therapy.
It doesn't always work,
but sometimes it does.
Yeah.
I wonder all the time.
I know the reason why I said it is cause that's what happened at Kennison.
He got hit by a car and we was a little kid.
They said that when Kennison was young,
he was one way.
He was like normal,
regular cit and then he got hit by a car and like real bad.
And then when he got out of whatever the fuck he was in it,
all of a sudden he was Kennison wild,
impulsive,
didn't get a fuck.
Oh.
He came that wild,
crazy preacher guy like literally became that from a car accident.
When you start talking tbis and traumatic brain injuries and that who is walking
into these facilities?
Oh yeah.
It's amazing how fucking arrogant the psychiatrist act because we literally know
almost nothing about real tbis.
You know where the brain,
you get hit here.
It could do this.
It could be that rule.
No.
So what happens is a guy who walks in who has a traumatic brain injury,
definitely Tbi.
What they start doing is playing with psychotropic medication and they start
saying,
well,
if it's in this area and this is the behavior,
so they throw you a six,
seven cocktails of pills hoping yeah,
can sense the right way in any depressants or the same fucking way.
And I tell people,
man,
the last thing you want to do is go right to a fucking antidepressant before you
do any thing.
Don't do that yet.
And once,
because once you start to walk down that road,
it can,
it can be years before you baseline again.
So it's like a one flew over the cuckoo's nest,
but just a more sophisticated version,
but still just as chaotic fucking guessing.
That's why they'll tell you an Ssri won't work for you your whole life.
This will work for a while,
but we got to try these nine until we find the one that does this one to work
for a while.
Then when it doesn't,
we'll switch.
And this Gary,
as part,
I had a,
it's a want to be podcast,
but I was just having fun with it.
Uh,
it was called the cognitive rampage.
I think all podcasts are want to be podcasts.
You don't know legitimate podcast.
This is totally a legitimate,
this is a real mad as fuck.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of,
but not really.
Trust me.
I'll show you [inaudible] podcast Ryan and I know the origins of it,
but I had a,
can I say a doctor's name here?
I had a bipolar list,
no name a Chicago.
Dr Brodsky.
Dr. Lewis Brodsky,
and he's,
all he's done is focused on,
on bipolar.
And so what his issue is is most people,
they'll walk into a facility,
right?
They'll get,
they'll,
75% of them are getting diagnosed with depression,
right?
Here's your antidepressant out the door.
The doc spent three minutes with your general practitioner,
asks you some sadness questions.
You fit the criteria,
tried to try and depressed and they don't tell you you're about to fuck your
whole chemical shit up.
You're about to screw your brain up.
But what happens though,
if you're bipolar truly,
and you take an antidepressant,
the first two or three days,
you're gonna feel like God,
you're going to feel like everything has been fixed him in better in my life and
think you have the right pill.
Every doctor at that point should know,
oh shit,
we fucked up.
You give someone who's bipolar,
an antidepressant or SSR.
I's and they cycle faster,
almost twice to three times faster than they ever cycled before in their life.
Wow.
So how,
think about how many people are going to a doctor.
Talk about some typical sadness or depression.
Here's Zoloft or some shit.
You go home and they're like,
man,
this is great.
I left side field,
I'm getting a little tangential,
but had a guy,
both his sons killed themselves and I was counseling him.
Doc gave him thought he was depressed,
gave me any depressant.
The second day after it he said,
I'm over at all.
All of this was meant to happen.
You tell that's not natural and he was happy and ready to go,
ready to go.
And then two days later starts to cycle hard from manic to heavy manic to
suicidal manic.
That stuff works for like,
my dad's going to be 80 you know,
and I got an uncle who's 85 and that's when it works.
The antidepressant helped them both.
You know what I mean?
But that's like you said,
he's for some people,
the people that I know that have worked for,
that has worked for out of them.
I know a few,
but two of them have cycled off of it.
It helped them,
they fixed their life,
they've got their life in order and then once her life was ordered than the
weaned himself off of it.
How you're supposed to do it.
Yeah.
Well they,
they both did it that way.
One of my friends from Jujitsu when a comedian friend of mine,
yeah,
they,
they definitely work.
I don't want,
I wouldn't bash that at all.
But as your first go to,
there's a lot of the things you can try,
you know,
changing your routine,
trying to find different things to get involved with.
There's a lot of things to do before you start going the quick magic pill for.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well listen man,
thanks for doing this.
I'm glad I met you last night.
It was a fortuitous opportunity to have a conversation with you and I knew that
we would have a cool talk.
I mean this,
I've know,
I've very rarely do this,
so to have someone in like perfect symmetry,
right?
Fig did worked out.
The fucking universe is looking out for us.
Nick Dipaolo,
ladies and gentlemen,
when the funniest comics in the world for sure.
Nick [inaudible] dot com nick depth.com.
What is the,
the the album,
they can still be another senseless killing if you use the,
uh,
the coupon code.
Nick,
you get three bucks off a hit me up and Nick Dipaolo Twitter,
my podcasts at [inaudible] dot com and I'll be at the Ventura harbor comedy club
tonight.
Can this Harris Ventura Harbor Comedy Club in Ventura,
California tonight?
Find me it Adam lowry.com or the cognitive rampage.
[inaudible],
spelled l,
O w e r y,
Adam lowery.com.
Brian Red van is doing a water show with burlesque dancers and electrical cords
all throughout Canada.
That's,
I'm here now.
I'm going to be next Thursday or next Thursday.
Yeah,
next Thursday I'd be with Dean del Ray at the San Jose Improv,
and then August 5th I have a secret show at the comedy store.
It's my birthday show,
so that's gonna be a lot of fun,
glorious venture.
He'll be 60 Gloria's tonight.
You tonight at the Visionary Ventura Harbor Comedy Club.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that's it.
We'll see you next week.
Until then,
much love.
Bye Bye.
And Big Kiss.
That was good.
One.